Ich bin links.
Hast dein Text vergessen?
Du bist wieder links, ja, ich hab's wieder richtig eingestellt.
Und ich bin wieder rechts.
Du bist wieder rechts. Und ich bin wieder in der Mitte. Ja, hallo, hier ist Mo bei Max und wir sind gerade eigentlich total unvorbereitet und haben auch mal festgestellt, dass es eigentlich gar nichts zu erzählen gibt, oder? Und deswegen können wir uns jetzt auch mal auf Belanglosigkeiten konzentrieren. Im Gegensatz zu sonst. Im Gegensatz zu sonst. Wir können uns noch mal vorstellen.
Fange ich an, ich bin Max, hallo.
Stellt man sich selber vor oder stellt man die anderen vor?
Man stellt die anderen vor.
Und der stellt dann wen vor? Stellen wir dann immer den zur rechten oder zur linken vor?
Also links von mir ist Max, aber es stimmt mich sich rechts.
Das ist dann ja albern.
So kommen wir dann nicht drauf.
Ja, ich bin Dennis, damit man meine Stimme, meinen Namen zuordnen kann.
Sonst können wir uns ja nicht gebacken.
Du bist der Darth Vader des McIntosh Podcasts.
Womit der nächste Hinweis gegeben wird, dass du von Drogenglisch aufnimmst. Wir haben nicht miteinander rumgeknutscht.
Ich bin Prinzessin Leia. So, jetzt hast du ja doch gesagt, dass du Dennis bist. Ich muss ja jemand anders sagen, dass du Dennis bist.
Ja, aber dann hören die ja meine Stimme nicht. Es ist ja kein Fernsehen hier.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Okay, das heißt, wir müssen uns doch wieder jeder selber vorstellen. Okay, also ich bin Tim.
Ich bin Max.
Und wir sind zusammen, wie immer.
Die drei von der Tankstelle.
Die drei von der Tankstelle. Und wir besichtigen...
Apropos Tankstelle, es war ein Erlebnis, hier beim Einparken zuzusehen. Eben.
Ich war im Stress. Dennis ist ungenießbar, wenn er keine kalte Club-Marte kriegt. Und ich hatte nur noch wenige Minuten Zeit. Und ich hab das hier in den letzten 15 Minuten noch abgerockt.
Ja.
Ja, da kann das schon mal passieren. Da nimmt man schon mal einen Bohrenstein mit. Aber es war nur Plastik.
Der Bordstein?
Jetzt schon.
Ja, nein, die Bordsteine hier im Prenzlauer Berg, die sind ziemlich fies irgendwie. Die sind hoch und unberechenbar. So wie Mac OS X. Was für eine Überleitung, was? Aber echt, also ich meine, ich stoch herum. Hier beim letzten Live-Podcast Chaos Radio Express mach ich ja jetzt immer einmal die Woche live auf UKW hier auf der Funkwelle. Und da muss ja dann immer wieder alles auf den Punkt. Das ist nicht so wie beim Podcasting, wo man dann anfängt, wenn dann mal endlich alles funktioniert, sondern da schlägt es einfach 13 und dann muss man loslegen. Und was war die Kiste? Ist eingefroren. Dann hatte ich gestern auch, also ich hab da sowas wieder häufiger. Hast du das iPhone jetzt installiert? Du installierst ja auch immer die komische Sachen. Da sag ich, ist doch egal, was ich installiere, das Ding darf sich auf keinen Fall aufhängen. Und in dieser Diskussion stecken wir schon seit Jahren.
Aber du hast den Dennis-Part sehr überzeugt gesprochen.
Den Dennis-Part?
Egal, du hast Dennis ein bisschen imitiert. Wollen wir mal anfangen?
Wir haben schon angefangen, wir sind dabei, wir sind mittendrin sozusagen. Und wir haben jetzt erst mal festgestellt, dass es eigentlich nicht viel Neues gibt. Aber immerhin gibt es mal wieder ein bisschen Gerüchteküche.
Wir können ein bisschen rückwirkend auf unsere alten Sendungen eingehen. Dann können wir zwei, drei Sachen noch kurz erwähnen.
Ach du meinst jetzt, wo wir die zehnte Sendung haben, machen wir einfach ein Medley der alten Sendung?
Nee, aber zum Beispiel haben wir ja in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung spekuliert, weil Ahnung hatten wir ja noch keine, ob jetzt nun der Squirrel-Fisch hieß der so.
Ja.
Ob der nun im iPhone drin ist oder nicht, das ist diese schnellere Java-Engine. Darüber haben wir spekuliert, ob das da drin ist. Genau, haben wir entschlossen, das ist nicht drin, weil es wäre noch ein bisschen zu früh für das iPhone.
Und so ist es auch.
Und der John Gruber von Daring Firewall hat irgendwie wohl gemessen mit irgendwie so der Stack-Tiefe oder sowas. Wo könnte man das irgendwie messen, weil das nach 1000 Loops oder so irgendwie so ein JavaScript irgendwie aufhört. Genau, und beim iPhone hat das auch getestet und das war definitiv noch kein JavaScript.
Ja, aber trotzdem hat er festgestellt, dass es die iPhone 2.0-Software, der Safari, erheblich viel schneller geworden ist, so oder so. Und dass man sogar davon ausgehen kann, dass es noch schneller wird.
Safari ist ja bei 3.1.
Ich rede von dem Mobile Safari jetzt.
Okay, okay.
Also von der iPhone-Software. Ich weiß nicht, hat das Mobile Safari auch eine spezielle Versionsnummer eigentlich?
Ja, die kannst du sehen in der User-Agent-Wende, der Webblock.
Ich glaub, das sind im Wesentlichen die Bildnummern, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht gerade. Aber kann man ja mal gucken.
Ja, das sind die Bildnummern.
Mit anderen Worten, wir sind schon wieder voll im iPhone-Thema.
Nee, nee, wollte ich nur mal kurz sagen, dass es also bestätigt ist, weil es, wie wir es schon seit Wochen gewusst haben, wissenschaftlich auch bewiesen wurde. Und die andere Sache...
Wir haben es schon immer geahnt.
Genau. Und andere mussten Blut und Wasser schwitzen, um es dann auch wirklich auszufinden. Die andere Sache, was ich noch gerne nachtragen würde, weil es war ja auch schon öfter mal Thema, immer mal wieder sozusagen, ist dieses iVPN.
Das kostet jetzt Geld, ne?
Genau, das kostet nämlich Geld. Der ist wohl ein relativ junger Entwickler, hat irgendwann von einer 2.4.0 zu einer 2.5.0 plötzlich gemeint, er will jetzt mal 30 Dollar dafür haben. Und dann haben natürlich viele geflucht und so weiter und so fort. Also zur Not muss man sich halt eine alte 2.4.0-Version besorgen, wenn man nicht bezahlen will, weil die tut ja eigentlich genauso.
30 Dollar finde ich sehr unangemessen.
Vor allem ist es wirklich nur ein Command-Line-Rapper, also könnt ihr schon, ich hab's mir jetzt nicht genau angeguckt, aber er macht ja nichts weiter als ein PPP, irgendwie Command-Line zu starten. Und mehr ist es ja nicht, zur Not noch IPSEC, aber das ist...
Besonders schick ist es auch nicht. Vom user interface, ja.
Also das ist schon okay, man kann auch für so eine Programme Geld nehmen, aber keine 30 Dollar.
Ich find ja so diese Preise, die sich jetzt so mit dem Upstore auf dem iPhone so einfassen.
Hast du das 1000 Dollar Programm gesehen?
799 Euro.
In Deutschland, ja.
Achso. 1000 Dollar, 799 Euro.
Genau.
Ich hab jetzt gerade nochmal nachgeguckt.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Idee. Wie hieß es? Einfach nur ein Icon, was auf dem iPhone ist.
Ich hab mir auch schon ein 10.000 Dollar Programm überlegt. Da steht dann nur I am Paris Hilton. Ich denk mal, es wird nur einmal verkauft. Wenn es sich zweimal verkauft, dann ist es... Dann ist einer ein Lügner.
Hat Paris Hilton denn überhaupt ein iPhone?
Ja, hat wohl ein iPhone.
Bestimmt.
Ich hab jetzt gerade nochmal nachgeguckt. Also der Safari auf dem iPhone gibt sich aus als Mozilla, blablabla, Version 3.1.1, mobile.
Nochmal, wie ist die Nummer?
3.1.1, mobile.
Das entspricht sozusagen schon auch der eigentlichen Safari bei uns nochmal.
Offensichtlich.
Und du hast aber auch noch nur eine 2.0, ne?
Ich hab nur eine 2.0, iPhone S 2.0, Like Mac OS X.
Warum? Hast du Angst vor der 2.0.1?
Es gibt noch keinen Jailbreak dafür.
Aber ist mal wieder gebroken, ne?
Also es ist wohl möglich, man kann ein Update drauf installieren, aber dann hat man noch keinen Jailbreak mehr. Aber der Simpanlock müsste eigentlich noch gehen.
Und ich hab gelesen, dass es auf dem 3G-iPhone auch den Baseband sich aktualisiert vorfindet. Was wahrscheinlich das potenzielle Unlocking erstmal wieder ein bisschen nach hinten schiebt. Ich hab jemanden behaupten sehen, dass sie irgendwie in Kanada da mal was ge-unlockt haben, aber vielleicht war es ein Fake. Ehrlich gesagt hab ich an einer Woche nicht wieder was davon gehört.
Also sie haben es geschafft wohl, eine ältere Beta-Version der Spacebands aufzuspielen auf das 3G-iPhone. Sie haben eine Entwicklungsumgebung geschaffen, mit der sie testen können, ohne sich ernsthaft Sorgen machen zu müssen. Also mit der sie immer wieder in den Originalzustand zurückkommen. Das ist das, was das Dev-Team bisher hat. Und es gibt ein paar Hardware-Unlocks, also diese berühmten Sachen, wo man eine spezielle SIM-Karte braucht. Und damit kriegt man es dann hin, was es ja zu 1.0er-Zeiten auch gab.
Aber es gibt eine einfache Methode, sein Telefon zu unlocken. Man kauft es in Italien.
Kaufst du schon?
Ich hab's nicht, denn die Dinger sind nicht zu kriegen. Ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Mal versucht, Leute loszuschicken, die aber bisher nur auf leere Läden und vollkommen genervte Mitarbeiter stoßen, die dann auch alle möglichen Nebelkerzen werfen mit irgendwie Ja, nee, wir haben gar keine unlocked iPhones, geht weg. Wir wollen mit euch nichts zu tun haben, ihr Kunden, geht weg. Die können einfach nicht, die können gar nicht so schnell die Teile reinholen, wie sie sie rausstoßen.
Aber angeblich baut doch Apple wie viel? 40 Millionen, nee, was?
Ja, also das Gerücht geht, dass sie jetzt ihre Produktion auf 800.000 iPhones pro Woche hauen. Pro Woche, war das okay?
Das ist ganz schön fille, ne?
Das ist ganz schön fille, das würden so 40 Millionen im Jahr sein oder so. Hätte ich das richtig gerechnet? Oder hat jemand anderes das für mich richtig gerechnet? Was ist denn? Früher könnte man sowas ja im Kopf, ne?
Ja, aber gut, dass die Zeit vorbei ist. 40.000, 1, 2, 3, geteilt ich 800.000, 1.000, 2.000, 3.000.
Ja, Weihnachtswoche.
Wenn man 50 Wochen rechnet, dann ist 800.000 mal 50 sind 40 Millionen.
Mir ist während ich das Eintipp da aufgefallen, dass kann ich auch heute noch im Kopf rechnen.
Ist das so?
Ja, das sind 50 mal 800.000.
Warum ist das jetzt auf deinem Schirm ein Risiko?
Weil ich es beim Eintippen und den Sicherheitshalber auch noch mal nachschauen wollte. Ich überprüfe immer noch das, was mein Rechner ausreicht.
Jaja, also das finde ich eine bemerkenswerte Zahl, wenn sie denn stimmt. Das ist mal wieder so aus gut unterrichteten Kreisen. Ich glaube TechCrunch hat die Story gebracht und sie waren sich da wohl sehr sicher. Keine Ahnung, mich würde es nicht wundern, weil der Hype ist einfach enorm und die Tatsache, dass wahrscheinlich werden 400.000 davon in Italien verkauft pro Woche. Also warum ich das jetzt noch mal erwähne, das ist ja eigentlich keine neue Information. Ich habe jetzt bloß aus einer persönlichen Quelle konkret erfahren, da wurde ein iPhone gekauft, in dem Fall bei Vodafone. Es wurde nach Deutschland geschippt und konnte einfach ohne Murren und Knurren mit einer E-Plus-Karte aktiviert werden.
Auch mit der 2.0.1. Weil die damals ja wieder ein paar Probleme gegeben haben, oder mit Vodafone und 2.0.1.
Ja, aber sowas muss ja trotzdem funktionieren, wenn die sagen, es ist anlockt, ist es anlockt.
Ja, aber es gab am Anfang...
Es gab irgendwelche Berichte, aber das kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen. Ich kann dir nur sagen, an sich funktioniert das. Das heißt, wer so einen Teil haben will, man kriegt das halt für 500 Euro. 8 GB wohlgemerkt.
500 Euro für 8 GB?
16 GB Phones gibt es überhaupt nicht. Und 8 GB gibt es ab und zu mal, wenn du so ein bisschen in den Pampa fährst. Also in den großen Städten sind die einfach weg und in den kleineren Städten hast du wohl eine Chance. Das ist so ein Ton, den man einfach bei Podcasts nicht machen sollte, weil der kommt eigentlich nur, wenn man dazu noch ein dummes Gesicht macht. Und das kommt ja, wie du weißt.
Stell dir mal von Tim ein dummes Gesicht vor.
So jetzt.
War das dumm genug? Ich hab es jetzt auch extra schön dumm klingt gemacht.
Also Tim hat immer noch kein IPhone heißes.
Ich hab immer noch kein IPhone. Ich bin jetzt schon so weit einzukommen. Ich hab jetzt auch mal ein bisschen auf Ebay gehovert und mal so geschaut, für was die Alten weggehen.
Und?
Frechheit. Also 16 GB kriegste so zwischen, je nachdem, 350 bis 400 Euro. So in dem Range gehen die weg. Und ich glaub, die 8 GB eher so um 300 Euro bereit.
Wie, das heißt, ich krieg weniger als ich für bezahlt habe?
Wieso, was hast du denn dafür bezahlt?
300 Euro. Achso, 300 Euro für die 8 GB. Ich dachte jetzt 250 oder so.
Du kriegst dasselbe. Oder mehr. Gut. Also die Leute sind...
Ich hab 270 bezahlt, aber ist ja leider schon runtergefallen.
Das ist egal, die Leute kaufen dir das auch noch, wenn du das irgendwie vorher ins Klo getunkt hast. Weil das noch funktioniert natürlich.
Klar funktioniert das.
Aber mit dem Bassband...
Da beweist sich auch mal wieder, Apple-Hardware ist nicht teuer.
Mit dem Bassband...
Weil man kann den nach zwei Jahren immer wieder zum Einkaufspreis...
Und ich hab jetzt auch schon meine eigene Software drauf.
Ist wahr? Über die du nicht reden darfst?
Genau.
Na toll, warum willst du das dann überhaupt?
Na, weil man kann halt, wenn man es anlockt hat mit Jailbreak, jetzt seine eigene Software draufschieben, gibt es so ein Tool, mit dem man selbst signieren kann so. Und dann schiebt man seine eigene Software da drauf.
Ah, sozusagen ohne offiziellen Developer-Account.
Genau. Hab ich immer noch nicht, weil Apple kommt ja nicht aus der Tasche.
Ah, verstehe.
Mit den mobilen Services haben sie es ja nicht so.
Und geht das halbwegs mit dem Code-Signing und sowas?
Na, da gibt es von diesen... Also früher gab es ja diesen Installer, wenn man das iPhone gehackt hat. Den gibt es ja noch nicht wieder. Da sind die am basteln. Installer 4 wird irgendwann demnächst kommen. Deswegen gibt es jetzt einen anderen. Der heißt Züdja und arbeitet mit APT von Debian. Und da ist eine Anleitung bei, wie man das mit dem Signieren macht. Und der hat auch so ein Tool geschrieben, das heißt LDID. Und mit dem kann man seine Apps signieren, wenn sie auf dem iPhone sind. Also es ist halt auch ein Command-Land-Tool, was auf dem iPhone selbst ausgeführt wird. Der hatte wohl auch einen Source-Code oder ein Bild, was immer auf dem Mac ging, aber habe ich mich nicht weiter gekümmert. Wäre eigentlich noch cooler.
Und kriegt man das vernünftig? Wie ist der Prozess? Du bildest das in X-Code?
Ich bau das in X-Code, sag dann hier Bau für die Weiß und nicht für Simulator. Dann schiebe ich es mit SCP rüber, dann Signier es und dann schiebe ich es nach Slash Applications, wo die ganzen Programme liegen. Dann starte ich einmal das Springboard neu und dann wird es da aufgelistet.
Und geht das so mit... Also da kann man auch bestimmt ein schönes Skript für schreiben, dass das halbwegs automatisiert geht, oder?
Also ich glaube der Jailbreak, das wäre dann für mich aber auch noch interessant. Also, Unlocking ist so etwas, da würde ich mich nicht unbedingt so sehr auf so Ownage Tools verlassen wollen, aber der Jailbreak ist absolut erforderlich, weil man kriegt ja sonst einfach nicht die Software drauf, die man haben will.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, wenn ich erstmal diesen Account habe bei Apple, dann kann ich es ja offiziell irgendwie draufschieben und auch irgendwann in den Store stellen und so weiter.
Ja, aber du musst es auch in den Store stellen.
Nicht unbedingt, wenn du mir deine Apple UU ID gibst, dann kann ich dir ja eine Version machen, die nur für dich ist.
Ja gut, aber du weißt auch, was man will. Man will eigentlich so eine scheiß Applikation auf seine Webseite stellen und dann sollen die Leute sich das runterladen und fertig ist.
Ja, aber die meisten haben doch eh nicht gejailbreakt oder wenn, keine Ahnung und so weiter.
Na ja, aber es gibt gute Argumente. Also Beispiel, jetzt hier diese NetShare-Applikation, die ja es tatsächlich auf den Upstore geschafft hat, dann war sie wieder weg, dann war sie wieder da, dann war sie wieder weg. Und ich weiß nicht, ist sie jetzt wieder da oder ist sie schon wieder weg.
Ich glaube, die bleibt weg jetzt.
Die bleibt weg. Was macht sie?
Du hast kein dummes Gesicht gemacht.
Was macht das Teil?
Das war ein anderes Geräusch.
Was macht das Teil genau?
Das sorgt dafür, das macht wohl ein Socksproxy auf, dass du irgendwie deinem Browser was benutzt. Kann man im Browser was Socksproxy benutzen? Ich weiß gar nicht. Und dass du jedenfalls ein Socks5-Proxy hast und dass du den über das iPhone benutzen kannst.
Socksproxy kannst du systemweit bei Michael Oestern einfach einschalten. Oder so, ja. Das heißt, man hat dann die Funktionalität, dass das Internet, was über gprs-slash-umts aufs iPhone kommt, per WLAN über ein Computer-to-Computer-Network bereitgestellt wird.
Was ja laut Lizenz-Tralala-Zeugs nicht erlaubt ist. Zumindest bei AT&T nicht.
Genau. Und bestimmt auch nicht bei der Telekom. Und da haben sie alle total Angst davor. Kann ich auch verstehen.
Bei der Telekom ist es auch nicht erlaubt. Also bei der Telekom kann man sich doch explizit jetzt...
Die Telefonen klagt doch hier schon gegen alle möglichen VoIP-Anbieter und so.
Ja, aber bei denen kann man sich doch jetzt die Zweitkarte holen, damit man die dann in seinen HSDPA-Modem reinpacken kann.
Das stimmt nur insofern als... Ja, doch.
Oh Gott, ich dachte, du schreibst zu. Wie kommst du da jetzt wieder raus?
Eigentlich ist es Quatsch, ja.
Da ist eine ganze Menge Quatsch.
Stimmt, eigentlich ist es totaler Quatsch, jetzt wo es irgendwie Multisim gibt. Das geht ja über den Account, das geht dann auch irgendwie über OMTS. Was soll das Ding dann über das iPhone mehr absetzen können als... Und da haben sie auch irgendwie keine Kontrolle über die Applikationen. Also von daher ist das eigentlich sowieso totaler Blödsinn. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die so eine Angst haben vor speziellen Applikationen auf dem iPhone, wenn man das halt mit einer normalen OMTS-Karte, die man in seinen Rechner schiebt oder einen USB-Teil, auch machen kann.
Weil es nicht in allen Ländern so ist wie bei der Telekom.
Ja, das stimmt. So diese Multisim-Geschichte, ist das so was spezifisch Deutsches?
Ich glaube, das ist was deutsches.
Ist das so?
Ich glaube schon. Ich hab jetzt nicht die genauen Vertragsbedingungen in allen Ländern durchgelesen, aber es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das eine Idee der Telekom ist und nicht das AT&T das dann anders macht.
Ah gut, also das konkrete Angebot ist jetzt, mit dem iPhone-Vertrag zu bundeln, kenn ich nur bei der Telekom. Aber an sich, denke ich, gibt es das bestimmt auch noch woanders. Na ja, habt ihr diese NetShare-Applikation runtergeladen? Getestet? Nö. Braucht ihr nicht?
Ich hab's auch nicht runtergeladen.
Okay.
Ich hab ja... Also GPS macht das eh keinen sonderlichen Spaß, solange man noch das alte iPhone hat.
Und habt ihr gehört? Ähm, Apple hat sich wahrscheinlich eine Arm-Lizenz geholt.
Nee, das hab ich nicht gehört.
Ich hab da auch sowas gelesen, aber irgendwie nur so ein bisschen. Also es ist schon witzig, weil von wem wurde das mal gegründet?
Von Apple?
Ja, hatten wir auch schon mal eine Sendung.
Das haben wir schon mal erwähnt. Auch in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang mit der Bude PASemmy. Dann hat Jobs ja auch schon bekannt gegeben, dass die halt an Custom-Chips arbeiten werden für das iPhone und iPod Touch, also die iPod-Plattform. Das hat er gesagt. War in dem Sinne auch keine besondere Überraschung mehr. Nee, nee, jetzt muss man das erstmal zu Ende erzählen. Also was passiert ist, Arm hat seine Quartalszahlen bekannt gegeben. Advanced Risk Machines. Und da haben sie dann halt gesagt, ach ja, und übrigens, wir haben auch einen neuen Lizenznehmer, aber wir dürfen euch nicht sagen, wer es ist. Aber es handelt sich um einen well-known, irgendwie mobilen Plattform-Anbieter. Aber wir dürfen euch nicht sagen, wer es ist. Ring, ring, nudge, nudge, ring, ring, say no more. Und das ist eigentlich deutlich, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, die sind schon Lizenznehmer. Aber nur Apple ist es halt nicht. Apple war es halt früher mal, weil Apple hat den ersten Computer mit dem Arm überhaupt rausgebracht, wenn man jetzt mal von Archon absieht, genau, den Newton. Und das ist alles Arm und der Chef von PAsemi hat diese Strong-Arm-Architektur erfunden. Also das ist einfach ein Perfect Match. Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr guter Einkauf. Und ich rechne damit, dass die nächste Generation iPhone einfach mit einer hohen Integrationsdichte kommen wird, wo einfach viele, was weiß ich, wie viele Chips sie jetzt zusammengefasst bekommen, das weiß ich nicht, aber ihr Ziel ist ganz klar, einen Prozessor zu bauen, wo Grafik und was weiß ich, was sie da noch alles drin haben wollen, alles auf einem Chip ist und das Ding halt maximal Strom spart ist.
Und die das halt billig selber herstellen können und nicht teuer einkaufen müssen.
iPhone Nano, also so ein Blödsinn. Da glaub ich halt nicht dran. Nicht auch nur eine Sekunde.
Wie, ohne DVD-Brenner?
Das ist zum, wofür soll das denn sein? Mal ehrlich jetzt.
Ohne Display.
Sind wir uns da einig? iPhone Nano wird es nicht geben, oder?
Also nicht, nicht.
Was soll denn das sein?
Also ich glaube, die sind jetzt erst mal nach oben hin, dann haben sie noch Luft, aber nach unten hin.
Das denke ich auch. Kleiner wird es nicht, das Telefon.
Also kleiner, vielleicht dünner oder sowas, aber das ist dann der nächste Integrationsschnitt.
Genau. Sehr viel dünner müsste es eigentlich auch nicht werden. Ich meine, das liegt ja eigentlich ganz angenehm in der Hand, oder?
Das liegt ganz angenehm in der Hand, aber es könnte ruhig, also man kann es bisher noch schlecht, also zum Abhacken von Armen oder sowas verwenden.
Du, ich kann dir das auch gerne anschleifen.
Ja, was ist das, kann man dann... Das geht bestimmt, man könnte es noch leichter und kleiner und geht doch immer.
Übrigens im Kommentar zur letzten Sendung wurde auch wieder Streit eingefordert.
Stimmt, echt?
Ja, fand jemand toll den Streit. Ich hab jetzt leider nicht dazu gekommen, noch mal Fragen für diese Sendung zu machen. Letztes Mal haben wir damit auch eine ganze Stunde zugebracht.
Ja, hab ich schon gewohnt, gestern hab ich schon geklickt, es müsste ja mal wieder online sein, aber...
Ja, nee, kann ich leider nicht mitbinden, dienen.
Ich hab übrigens, haben wir schon erwähnt, haben wir offiziell erwähnt, dass wir gerade live streamen?
Nee, aber es ist ja nichts.
Es ist auch Blödsinn, das zu tun. Nee, es ist insofern kein Blödsinn, weil das, was ich gleich sage, bezieht sich darauf. Ich höre gerade, dass wir ein bisschen dumpf klingen im Stream und frag mich jetzt, ob das bei der Aufnahme so ist. Du hörst gerade oder du liest gerade? Ich lass mir sagen, ich lese gerade.
Ah, jetzt haben wir nämlich genau diese Feedback-Loop. Wenn man nämlich erstmal live podcastet, dann ist man die ganze Zeit...
Ich mach das gleich aus. Aber nicht, dass sich das auf die Qualität aus. Auf die Audioqualität.
Dumpf klingen.
Das war so ein bisschen dumpf und leise klingen.
Besser dumpf klingen.
Dumpf. Also ich weiß nicht. Ich könnte hier ein bisschen rumspielen. Wir könnten hier so ein bisschen Höhen reinmachen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das in der Aufnahme auch drin ist oder ob das nur im Stream ist. Wenn es nur im Stream ist, dann ist das Pech gehabt. Hört euch einen Podcast an.
Kann ich dir nicht sagen. Gut, ich kann aber hier mal so ein bisschen an Höhen. So ein paar Höhen, ist das jetzt besser?
Ich weiß nicht, dass wir nicht versehentlich wieder nur über deinen MacBook-Mikrofon streamen oder gerade aufnehmen.
Nein, nein, das ist alles super.
Und meinte, ob die auch irgendwann, also der Arm bisher wird ja nur im iPhone und im iPod Touch eingesetzt, ob der vielleicht auch in was Anderem eingesetzt wird?
Was Anderem? Was ist denn Anderem noch?
Einfach, weil mal wieder ein Plattformwechsel ansteht?
Weil es vielleicht billiger ist. Die Prozessoren haben so viel Power und vielleicht reicht es auch, wenn man mal was Kleineres nimmt.
Die haben Power für ein batterieschonendes Gerät, aber die haben nicht Power im Vergleich zu der Power, die du jetzt in so einem Core Duo drin hast.
Ich glaube da nicht so dran.
Ich denke, wir werden so schnell keine nennenswerten neuen Plattform-Geschichten sehen. Also sicherlich werden sie in irgendeiner Form die iPhone-Plattformen ausbauen. Aber eher noch im Hinblick auf ein zweites iPhone, was irgendwelche Bedürfnisse bedient, aber bestimmt nicht so ein Nano, sondern eher nur so, was weiß ich, nochmal ein 32GD. Oder was weiß ich, vielleicht fügen sie halt irgendwie ein teures Feature nochmal hinzu, wobei ich jetzt auch nicht so recht wüsste, was das sein sollte, was man in einer günstigen Variante nicht braucht.
Na wer weiß, vielleicht bauen wir ja noch ein neues Gerät, oder doch noch eine Spielekonsole?
Eine Spielekonsole?
Haben sie schon! Das iPhone ist eine Spielekonsole. Sieben von den zehn meistverkauften kostenpflichtigen Programmen sind alles Games. Und ich glaube, dass die Games-Developer sich gerade eine goldene Nase verdienen.
Und laut schreien.
Also das geht weg, wie warme Semmel. Ich meine, wenn sie in einer Woche 25 Millionen Downloads hatten, dann sind da vielleicht 10 Prozent bezahlte.
Ich hab gerade einen Tap offen, wo jemand sagt, wie viel hier Tap, Tap, Tap.
Also inzwischen gibt es ja Monkey Boy auch schon bei Pirate Bay. Also nicht nur Monkey Boy, sondern eigentlich alle Spiele aus dem App Store gibt es bei Pirate Bay.
Und wie kann man die sich installieren?
Du hast eine Jailbreak des Phones. Zwei verschiedene Packages bei Pirate Bay. Einmal kopierst du es mit SCP drauf. Und einmal kannst du es in den iTunes reinschmeißen und der kopiert es dann auf dein iPhone rüber. Also irgendwie gibt es da zwei verschiedene Pakete. Aber ich hab das natürlich nicht geprüft.
Ich hab geprüft und hab mich zu blöd angestellt.
Echt?
Also ich hab's draufgebracht und es wurde auch ein Iconspringboard angezeigt, aber...
Wobei ich das ehrlich gesagt nicht so recht verstehe bei dem Preis.
Ich wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Genau.
Ja, okay, ich färb das euch jetzt nicht vor, dass ihr es ausprobieren wolltet, aber so diese Energie jetzt, das geht wahrscheinlich einfach generell because we can.
Naja, nicht nur because we can, sondern...
Klar, weil du kannst nicht jetzt alle Spiele ausprobieren. Weil ich dachte mir, so ein Spiel würde ich da gerne mal austesten. Aber so richtig Bock hatte ich auch nicht, das zu bezahlen. Also hab ich es mal ausgetestet.
Das heißt, du hast noch nicht ein Spiel gekauft?
Natürlich nicht.
Hast du überhaupt schon was gekauft? Nee. Wieso nicht? Weil deine Kreditkarte nicht funktioniert.
Doch, ich hab jetzt über, wie heißt es, click and buy mich da angewählt. Ich hab mir irgendwie einen Cent gutgeschrieben, komischerweise auf meinem...
Was machen die damit?
Das ist der Kontotest.
Ja, genau. Das heißt, ich kann das ein paar hunderttausendmal machen und bin reich.
Ich glaub, die sperren die Konto nochmal nach dem ersten Mal.
Naja, ich glaub...
Das ist wahrscheinlich, wenn ich mich abmelde, buchen sie mich wieder zurück.
Ja, deine Kontogebühren werden das auf jeden Fall auffressen.
Ich halte es für nicht. Keine perfekte Geschäftsidee, sagen wir so.
Ich glaub auch nicht. Jedenfalls hab ich jetzt da so einen Account, hab jetzt auch schon mein Apple-Zeugs da irgendwie geklickt, aber wie gesagt, ich krieg das ja nicht durch. Irgendwie diese 100 Dollar für meinen Developer-Account klappt nicht, aber ich kann jetzt auf jeden Fall Programme shoppen. Und ich hab mir AIM bisher geholt und hier so ein Mandelbrot-Rechner. Mal wollte ich mal gucken. Und das Remote-Tool von Apple hab ich geholt, womit man sein iTunes Remote steuern kann. Das ist ganz nett, aber...
Also alles kostenlos?
Natürlich.
Und dann hast du nur drei Sachen runtergeladen?
Ja, ich hab jetzt keinen Bock, irgendwie alles mögliche.
Kein Flashlight, keine mehr Waage?
Nee.
Nein?
Eine Waage?
Oder irgendwie so ein Reichheitsdokumentations... Oder ein Armutsdokumentationsprojekt?
Auch meinst du, dieses I Am Rich Program für 1000 Dollar gibt's im nächsten Jahr auch bei Pirate Bay?
Naja, die Grafik kannst du ja als Screenshots schon aus dem Store irgendwie holen. Also mehr ist da ja nicht drin.
Man kann die sich selber schreiben.
Doch, man kann auf den E-Button klicken, und dann kommt so ein Mantra.
Die Idee ist irgendwie cool. Ich hoffe, dass er seine Verkäufe auch offenlegt. Ja, und ob das wirklich einer gemacht hat.
Dann schreibe ich ein I Am Smart Programm, was dann 10 Dollar kostet.
Naja, es geht auf jeden Fall vorbei.
Es geht vorbei.
Ja, es geht vorbei. Sag mal, Max, kennst du eigentlich den schon? Ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken, ob der Max das schon kennt. Wenn nicht, dann können wir sehen, dass wenn du hier draufklickst und festhältst, dass dann das kommt.
Das wird bei jeder neuen Firmware-Version getan. Also es ist, wenn man in... Sind wir zu jeder die ganze Zeit schon beim Anfang? Sehr gut.
Sind wir auf Sendung?
Wenn man in Safari auf den Punkt Komm-Button unten klickt und den ein bisschen gedrückt hält, dann geht da so ein Pop-Up-Menü auf. Dann steht da noch DE und ORG und NET und so was alles drin, dass man das noch dazu hinzufügen kann. Das habe ich das erste Mal gesehen auf der Pressekonferenz von Apple, also der Telekom, als sie das vorgestellt haben am 11. Als sie es angekündigt haben.
Ich habe das auch erst letztendlich entdeckt. Ich finde das immer voll toll, wenn man so Sachen entdeckt, die man vorher noch nicht wusste.
Die es schon immer gab.
Das ist bei jeder neuen Version der Firmware. Da steht irgendwo in Tuaf drin. Übrigens, mit dieser Firmware kann man auch, wenn man den Button gedrückt hält, dann kommt da mehr Auswahl.
Wie das so ist.
Hast du auch schon gewusst, dass wenn man hier drin, dass man da drin scrollen kann und sich mehr Einträge machen kann?
Dennis, wir sind ein Audiopodcast.
Mann, no. Weil es bei dem Aktienteil ist vom iPhone, kann man noch hoch und runter scrollen. Das Aktienprogramm benutzen, aber keine Kategorik.
Wir wollen uns doch jetzt hier im Podcast nicht darüber unterhalten, dass man in den Aktien rumscrollen kann.
Ja, ich dachte, das geht nicht.
Ich bringe mal das Thema mal auf was Neues. Sehr gut. Interessanterweise gibt es in Australien jetzt schon den vierten Telefonprovider, der das iPhone hat. Offiziell. Was? Vier Telekom-Unternehmen.
Und alle aber mit Locking.
Soweit ich weiß, weiß ich gerade nicht, wie das überhaupt in Australien ist.
Das ist ganz schön weit weg vor allem.
Ist Australien nicht eines derjenigen, die unlockt sind?
Weiß ich nicht. Aber von da einst die Härte kriegen... Hatten wir...
Es ist sinnlos. Ich sag dir Italien.
Hast aber auch noch keins.
Nein, hab ich nicht. Aber ich meine, wenn sie wirklich 800.000...
Guck mal, ich und Max, wir halten uns extra zurück, damit erst mal du eins kriegst. Aber wir haben ja schon eins. Und wenn du eins hast, dann legen wir los.
Hab ich das eigentlich verlinkt, diesen Link irgendwie, wobei Apple...
Nee, ich warte einfach, dass meine Eltern in die Schweiz fahren und mir hoffentlich eins mitbringen.
Aus der Schweiz?
Aus der Schweiz.
Und das ist aber gelockt.
Das ist gelockt und dann fängt das große, dann werde ich hier bibbernd sitzen, wie ein Heroin-Abhängiger auf Entzug und...
Immer warten, bis der Anlockung kommt.
Bis zwei Sekunden takt die Def.iPhone-Seite reloaden.
Wie auch immer. Also in den USA bleibt auf jeden Fall alles beim Alten. Bis 2010 wird AT&T da weiterhin dabei sein. Habt ihr schon diese 2.1-Version irgendwie schon mal irgendwo?
2.1? Die 2.1 Beta-2-Meinze, die es gibt. Die ist ja nur für selected developers und zwar angeblich für welche, die schon bis zum 9.7., also die ersten 4000, die schon vorher von Apple aufgenommen wurden, die sozusagen noch handfalllesen aufgenommen wurden, die haben das wohl bekommen und da ist noch nichts geleakt. Ich hab irgendwie hier bei unserer Piratenbucht mal geguckt, da gibt es eigentlich immer alles so. Und da ist noch nichts aufgetaucht, aber von der Beta 1 meinten sie auch, die wäre irgendwie total buggy und nicht benutzbar und komisch und die haben die gleich alle wieder runtergenommen. Was wohl auch geht?
Das kann ja sein, aber ich finde die Features, die sie in Aussicht gestellt haben, zumindest dem ich mir den Berichten da halbwegs glauben schenke, da finde ich es sehr interessant.
Welche?
Na ja, also erstmal ist wohl Copy und Paste dann tatsächlich da, wobei ich nicht...
Nee, das sieht wohl alles eher wieder schlecht aus.
Also es ist so, dass die ja in der Firmware so nach Keywords gesucht haben, so mit dem String-Commandos oder Strings und haben da so Sachen gefunden, so Texte, die halt sich danach anhören. Aber dann wurde auch schon berichtet, diese Strings, die waren in einer 1er Firmware, da waren diese Strings auch schon alle drin. Und das Gleiche für... Was wurde da noch gefunden?
Das GPS, dass eine Kompass-Funktion rein soll und das...
Die Strings wurden auch alle... Also es hat sich herausgestellt, dass es alles schon alte Hüte sind.
Alles schon alte Hüte.
Und die Strings auch schon in den alten Hüten.
Und vielleicht doch noch den angekündigten Push-Notification-Dienst und...
Wahrscheinlich. Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass das 2.1, weil wenn dieses Push-Notification-Zeug kommt, heißt es ja, dass die ihre APIs ein bisschen ändern. Oder zumindest, wenn ein neuer kommt. Und vielleicht kommen ja auch so für Developer da so ein paar neue Features. So ein Beispiel, Ordentlich-XML-Support, weil den gibt's ja nicht.
Meinst du, dass sich da noch mal signifikant was ändern wird an der API?
Hoff ich.
Sodass die alten Programme nicht mehr laufen, oder was?
Nee, nicht mehr, nicht. Nee, die alte wird so bleiben, aber dass so neue Sachen dazu kommen noch.
Die wird doch ziemlich sicher ausgebaut.
Das ist ja eine Null-Aussage. Natürlich werden da neue Sachen dazu kommen, sonst braucht sie ja keine neue Version rauszuhauen.
Na vielleicht, damit die Alte wenigstens nicht so wie die läuft.
Naja, ob da, ich glaub nicht, dass sie jetzt so schnell alte Sachen rausnehmen, dann müssen die Leute ja wirklich neue coden. Aber wir wissen ja auch, dass irgendwie Apple mit Rausschmeißen von alten Sachen immer ganz vorne mit dabei ist. Also wenn man sich guckt hier bei 10.3, 10.4, 10.5, was da immer gleich deep recatet ist und was man nicht mehr benutzen darf. Und da sind die sogar relativ fix. Also in 10.4 haben die schon zwei Rausschmeißen, was in 10.5 dann wirklich schon nicht mehr da ist.
Eine Sache ist neu. Sie haben das scheiß Teil released, aber es ist immer noch alles unter NDA. Und alle Developer sind am kotzen.
Es gibt da eine Seite, die heißt das Fuck NDA?
Fucking nda.com oder so. Ja, das ist so ein Twitter-Extrakt, wo Developer, die über das NDA schimpfen.
Angeblich, damit Fremdfirmen dann nicht reingucken. In so einen Blödsinn, die gucken ja trotzdem rein.
Naja, das ist nicht ganz so einfach gesagt, weil ich habe jetzt das NDA nicht im Einzelnen gelesen, aber es schließt sozusagen bestimmte Leute aus, dass die das sozusagen offiziell, also unter den Bedingungen dürften sie halt nicht für Konkurrenten arbeiten. So habe ich das rausgelesen und das gibt sozusagen theoretisch Apple einen Hebel in die Hand, den dann irgendwie auf die Finger zu hauen, wenn die halt irgendwie was, keine Ahnung, frage mich nicht, ich verstehe es nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, ich verstehe es nicht. Ich finde das alles ein bisschen albern. Also ich finde es sehr schade. Und vor allem ist es ein echtes Problem. Und auch diese Sache, wo wir letztes Mal so ein bisschen irgendwie abgeratet haben, hier gegen die Free Software Foundation. Und diese Aussage, dass freie Software ja nicht möglich ist. Da müssen wir auch nochmal ein bisschen zurückrudern, weil es ist in der Tat schwierig, weil wenn man die GPL jetzt wirklich genau auslegt, dann widerspricht der App Store schon der Lizenz. Weil ja freie Software, da geht es ja nicht nur darum, dass der Source Code verfügbar ist, sondern dass du dann halt sozusagen freies Software reliest, dann musst du ja die Möglichkeit haben, diesen Source Code zu nehmen, anzupassen und für dich sozusagen zum Laufen zu bringen. Oh Gott, jetzt komme ich schon wieder ins Schleudern.
Dass man den halt selber bauen könnte, ja?
Ja, also diese eingeschränkten Distributionswege widersprechen, sozusagen. Da kann man natürlich jetzt, ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Ich meine letzten Endes ist das Apple, glaube ich, zum derzeitigen Zeitpunkt ziemlich wurscht. Ihnen geht es vor allem darum, diese Plattformen secure und unter ihren Bedingungen weiterzuentwickeln. Und wenn man dann halt nicht mit freier Software arbeiten kann, dann ist Ihnen das auch glaube ich ziemlich egal. Aber es ist insofern ein Problem, dass wenn du jetzt wirklich eine Applikation Open Source entwickeln möchtest, unter den Bedingungen der NDA derzeit, darfst du halt noch nicht mal den Code in irgendein Subversion Repository einchecken. Also wo halt andere Leute theoretisch dann Zugriff haben auf diesen Source Code, weil dieses zugänglich machende Source Code wäre sozusagen eine Dokumentation des APIs und damit brichst du halt dein NDA. Das heißt, du kannst derzeit einfach auch nicht wirklich Open Source entwickeln.
Aber es wird trotzdem gemacht.
Das weiß ich nicht so genau. Wie ist denn das mit diesem WordPress Ding?
Ist das schon gelöst? Das WordPress Ding ist released. Das kann man sich runterladen. Ich hab's mir runtergeladen, hab's kompiliert, lief auch problemlos im Simulator. Insofern scheint das komplett zu sein.
Ich klag dich weg.
Wieso mich? Also die haben's einfach gemacht und warten jetzt wahrscheinlich drauf, bis sie von Apple verklagt werden und ob sie von Apple verklagt werden. Und wenn sie verklagt werden, haben sie eine schöne Buchquelle, auf der sie schwimmen können, nehme ich an.
Wer?
WordPress, also automatic.
Ich glaub, da wird das Netz ganz schön einhauen auf Apple. Das stimmt. Insofern können sie das alles gar nicht halten. Also ich finde es albern. Ich finde es unverständlich, warum sie auf dieses NDA bestehen. Und mir ist zumindest nicht klar, was sie jetzt damit eigentlich bezwecken. Weil es ist einfach ein totales Hindernis.
Die haben es wahrscheinlich einfach vergessen, bei dem ganzen Mobile-Me-Stress.
Na ja, aber irgendjemand sollte doch auch ein paar Blogs da draußen lesen.
Das ist jetzt schon auch irgendwie eine Weile da draußen. Also wenn sie das nur vergessen hätten, dann hätten sie es schnell wieder abschalten können.
Also es verhindert vor allen Dingen so unglaublich viel, weil ich finde es ja durchaus mal ganz interessant. Ich hätte jetzt einen Punkt, an den ich mir zutrauen würde, eine Mini-Applikation mal zu entwickeln. Vielleicht kann ich es so schwer sein. Und wenn ich irgendwo ein schönes Tutorial finden würde, mit dem ich einsteigen könnte, wahrscheinlich hätte ich jetzt am Wochenende mal was gemacht. Aber so habe ich das Wochenende rumgesessen, in irgendwelchen dämlichen Apple-Dokumentationen mich da einzuarbeiten.
Weil einfach niemand drüber schreiben darf.
Weil niemand drüber schreiben kann, niemand Bücher drüber machen kann.
Es gibt ja den New York Channel iPhone Deaf und da wird einem gut geholfen. Hier werden sie geholfen.
Okay, dann muss ich noch vorhin Irg installieren. Ich bin kein Irg-Freund.
Ich auch nicht, aber das merkst du gar nicht. KoloKui, gehst du rein? Naja, ist ja so.
Das merkst du gar nicht. Sieht aus wie ein richtiges Programm.
Das merkt man nicht.
Dass man im Irg ist, wenn man KoloKui benutzt.
Ja, uns hören 26 Leute zu übrigens.
Okay, weil wir jetzt ja gerade so einen Themenprung haben, kann ich jetzt noch was so reinschieben. Und zwar gibt es ja seit, also ihr benutzt ja alle bitteren und auf dem Mac nutzt man natürlich Transmission, weil das ist am tollsten.
Da gab es ein neues Update.
Da gab es ein neues Update letzte Nacht.
Mit richtig geilen Features.
Mit richtig geilen Features und da will ich mal eins hervorheben. Und zwar kann man dort jetzt auch einzelne Trecker hinzufügen und auch entfernen.
Darauf habe ich ja schon immer gewartet. War das sehr ironisch? Nein, das war in der Tat mein... Ich habe es noch nicht begriffen, wie das User Interface dafür ist.
Was ich kurz erklären muss, warum es wichtig ist, es gibt seit schon ein paar Monaten, wenn man BitTorrent-Files bei Pirate Bay oder woanders runterlädt, dann sind immer zwei Trecker drin. Und zwar einmal der von Pirate Bay und einmal einer von moviex.com.
Der ist wo drin?
Nur in einem Torrent-File. Das sind einfach zwei Trecker eingetragen.
In allen?
Nö, in ganz vielen, aber.
Warum?
Das erkläre ich jetzt. Und diese MovieX ist eine eigene Community, die bringen ihre Torrents raus und packen ihre eigenen Trecker mit rein. Die Sache ist aber, dass der auf Registrierungszeugs besteht und einen gar nicht reinlässt, außer man ist halt Cedar. Das heißt, man hat schon alles und schiebt nur noch raus und kriegt nichts mehr. Das heißt, sie lehnen dich ab, solange du auch ein Downloader bist und nehmen dich erst auf, wenn du nur noch rausschieben bist, damit sie ihre eigene Community... Community. Ihre eigenen Jungs besser fördern können. Ihre eigenen Jungs besser fördern können. Und deswegen will man diesen Trecker rausnehmen, weil das ist sozusagen ein Sucker. Und das ist halt scheiße. Das ist gegen den Goodwill von BitTorrent.
Und deswegen hat er das eingebaut.
Unter anderem, nehme ich mal an.
Also ich wollte das ja aus anderen Gründen haben, nämlich wenn man wirklich nämlich mal das benutzen möchte, um selber eine Datei von A nach B zu bringen. Und was war... Du kennst den Fall, was weiß ich. Man hat jetzt irgendwie so ein DVD-Image und das liegt jetzt auf irgendeinem Server, der so ein bisschen wackelig angebunden ist. Und du kriegst halt einfach das Ding nicht mit AFP oder SCP in einem runtergeladen.
Das fehlt sowieso überhaupt noch im Netz.
Ja, Uploading und Downloading ist ein großes Problem. Und BitTorrent könnte da extrem helfen. Nur, dass es eben... Moment, ich bin so unkonzentriert heute. Also das geht natürlich, dann musst du aber deinen eigenen Tracker haben. Aber wenn es nur den einen Peer gibt, dann ist es ja eigentlich kein Problem. Woran wollte ich jetzt eigentlich reden?
Ich wollte davon, dass du das ganz toll findest, dass du mein eigener Tracker hinstellst und entfernen kannst.
Genau, wenn ich nämlich jetzt weiß, dass ich auf meinem fernen Rechner diese Datei schon habe und ich will es aber an einer anderen Stelle haben, und das ist so eine öffentlich verfügbare Sache, ich benutze den selben Ton, dann möchte ich halt gerne sagen, benutze meinen als extra Sida. Oder kann man nur Trecker hinzufügen? Man kann nur Trecker hinzufügen. Man kann gar nicht Pierce hinzufügen.
Wollte ich vor Jahren schon haben und da haben sie das Feature als too powerful abgelehnt. Vielleicht werden sie es jetzt demnächst ändern, aber mal gucken.
Kann mal jemand von euch die Gesprächsleitung übernehmen? Ich bin fertig.
Neue Transmission-Version, das ist die Version 1.3.0. Dort kann man Trecker hinzufügen und auch entfernen. Und diese moviex.com, irgendwie komische Passwortgeschichten, die sollte man einfach rausnehmen.
Aber da ist auch noch dieses Web-Interface, das ist jetzt auch noch dazugekommen, ne?
Das ist auch noch dazugekommen, ja. Da kann man halt remote irgendwie so eine Transmission per Web fernsteuern. Das ist eine ganz coole Sache für Leute, die BitTorrent Clients aus einem dicken Server laufen haben und den irgendwie remote bedienen wollen. Ich hab auch schon überlegt, ob ich dafür noch ein iPhone Client schreibe, damit man vom iPhone aus dann sein BitTorrent fernsteuern kann.
Das sieht auf dem iPhone relativ hütsch aus sogar.
Ich hab noch nicht die Webseite gemacht. Ich wollte es so als Direktprogramm machen.
Geht dir jetzt auch mit der neuen Version? Weil da ist ja auch gleich noch eine entsprechende JSON-Kommandos mit drin. Hab ich vorhin nur kurz gesehen, als ich das Update installiert habe.
Genau, es gibt da so eine JSON-basierte API.
Also von Transmission jetzt?
Ja, genau.
Ja, aber ich den ja mit diesem Charles heißt der da, bin ich auch immer im Irrg bei denen schon kurz gequatscht.
Sollte man erklären, was JSON ist?
Java, Zeugs irgendwie?
Nein, das ist JavaScript.
Das ist im Prinzip so eine Alternative zur XML, um Daten zu encapsulieren, die sehr populär ist derzeit im Web.
Die ist ganz hübsch, weil die ist sehr, sehr kompakt. XML neigt dazu, dass man sehr, sehr viele Daten hat.
Sehr lesbar auch.
Relativ lesbar. Und es ist nativer JavaScript-Code hier im Endeffekt, sodass jeder Browser das von vornherein ausführen kann.
Du musst halt nicht noch XML parsen.
Und man muss nicht erst irgendwas parsen und hin und her schieben und weiß ja teufel was, man nimmt einfach diese Daten, so wie sie sind und führt sie aus und hat ein JavaScript-Objekt.
JSON selbst wird aber vom iPhone nicht unterstützt, aber da gibt es ja genauso wie für XML, was auch nicht so ganz direkt unterstützt wird vom iPhone.
Die JSON wird nicht vom iPhone unterstützt.
Safari unterstützt das, klar.
Aber es gibt halt von dem Typen, der schon Touch-XML macht, gibt es auch Touch-JSON für das iPhone.
Touch-JSON, wieso was?
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Bibliothek, die man sein kann.
In Safari, sonst würden ja Millionen Webseiten gehen.
Ja, aber wenn du es aus deinem Programm direkt benutzen willst, könnte man ja direkt einen JSON-Encoder und Decoder anbauen.
Es gibt im US keinen Dienst dafür. Aber das ist ja simpel.
Simpel, simpel ist es nicht. Es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Ersatz dafür.
Touch-JSON heißt es.
War denn dieser Proxy-Support in Transmission auch schon vorher drin?
Proxy-Support, Proxy-Support. Die haben vor einer Weile auf die Curl-Lib umgeschaltet. Und ich glaube seitdem.
Man kann jetzt auch einen Trecker über einen Proxy erreichen.
Und auch, was für die Zukunft mal ganz wichtig sein könnte, ist, dass es auch jetzt HTTPS, also mit SSL, wird auch unterstützt, falls der Trecker in deiner SSL-Adresse sich versteckt. Weil die bei Pirate Bay haben ja vor, ich weiß nicht, ob ich ja schon zu viel verrate, auf über kurz oder lang komplett auf SSL umzuschalten.
Für die Trecker-Connection.
Ja, für die Webseite wahrscheinlich auch, aber auch für die Trecker, ja. Und wir reden da so bei Pirate Bay von 30.000 Connections pro Sekunde. Das heißt, da braucht man schon ein bisschen Hardware-Power, wenn man das alles mit SSL machen will.
Und ich sehe auch bei Transmission gibt es einen Blocklist-Feature.
Ja, bin ich ja nicht so fan von.
Prevent known Bad Peers from Connecting.
Ja, die nutzen ja diese Bluetech- oder Peer-Guard-Tralala-Geschichte, aber da war ja auch schon eine Menge Stress mit, weil unser Trecker, wir hatten ja auch mal die BitTorrent-Sendung, wir haben auch einen eigenen Trecker und der wurde da drin auch geblockt, weil, ach was weiß ich, lange Geschichte, die sind jedenfalls blöd, die Typen, die da diese Filterlisten machen und die filtern alles weg, was irgendwie denen nicht koscher ist. Und das ist aber inzwischen viel zu viel und deswegen, ich weiß nicht, man sollte nicht die Filterlisten von anderen Leuten übernehmen, weil da eine Menge Müll auch drin ist.
Verstehe, 222.628 IP-Adressen sind da drin, sagt er.
Wie viel?
222.000.
Netze oder einzelne Adressen?
IP-Adress-Rules.
Ja, das sind auch Netze teilweise. Irgendwer meinte, es wäre ein Viertel des Internets, wäre damit weggefiltert. Echt? Also das alles.
Ja, dann, was ist mir noch aufgefallen hier, wo wir noch am Nacharbeiten sind hier? LLVM, wir haben es schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Ja, genau, du hast gesagt, du hast News. Jetzt erzähl mal, ich weiß ja gar von nichts.
Naja, News ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Ein kleines Titbit ist mir da nur entgegengefallen. Dieser Chris Lettner, also der dieses LLVM gemacht hat, auf einer Webseite von ihm steht seine offizielle Jobdescription bei Apple. Und er ist dort Compiler, Toolchain, Manager und Compiler-Architekt.
Das war das schon, das Titbit?
Das ist das Titbit, aber das, finde ich, sagt schon mal eine ganze Menge aus. Also er ist halt nicht nur so ein lokaler kleiner Forschungsnerd, sondern er ist schon derjenige, der auch die Richtung der ganzen Compiler-Toolchain im Überblick hat und da halt seine Hauptprojekte LLVM und vor allem C lang, also der neue C-Compiler sind, deutet das auch wieder darauf hin, worüber wir schon gesprochen haben, dass das irgendwann in Xcode integriert wird. Dass das in diese Richtung geht. Das ist sicherlich nichts, was morgen stattfindet, aber ich habe immer mehr den Eindruck, dass sie einfach dahin wollen. Dass sie GCC abwerfen werden, sobald sie können und dass sie das durch C lang und halt LLVM ersetzen.
Was ich schon letztens auch gesehen habe, ist, ich bin ja auch immer bei den FreeBSD Change Logs am Lesen, was da so abgeht. Current heißt das, kann man nochmal verfolgen, was die so für Patches einspielen.
Warte, warte.
Und da hat auch letztens einer eine Änderung vorgenommen. Und zwar basierend auf einen Hinweis von einem C lang Source Analyzer. Also auch die befangen schon an diese Software zu benutzen, die über den Source rüber geht und versucht, irgendwie Memory Leaks oder sonst wie Sachen zu finden, weil die ein bisschen intelligenter rangehen können. Also das Tool breitet sich aus langsam.
Heißes Zeug ist das.
Das ist immer lustig. Außerhalb dieser vier Wände hier gelte ich als Nerd. Hier drin komme ich mir immer vor wie ein Kaninchen. Wirklich?
Wie ein Kaninchen?
Aber so geht es mir, wenn du JavaScript sagst. So geht es mir, wenn du JavaScript sagst.
Dann sage ich nochmal JavaScript.
Oh Gott, habe ich ja keine Ahnung von.
Das ist gar nicht so schwer. Wir können ja auch mal wieder in die Gerüchteküche gehen, da sind wir ja alle gleich. Neue MacBooks stehen an. Und dann gab es so ein blödes Bild irgendwie, was aussah, als hätte sich jemand ein MacBook Air genommen und das so lange rumgefotoshoppt, bis es aussieht wie ein neues MacBook.
Diese neuen Bilder, die sahen schon ein bisschen anders aus. Sie waren ja viel, viel kantiger.
Kantiger? Na, ich habe die hier gesehen.
Genau, das ist doch bei MacBook Air so. Guck mal an, wie dick das da oben ist. Das ist mehr.
Also warum sollte das Display ausgerechnet dicker sein?
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Schatten unten drunter, oder? Ein bisschen mehr Kontrast drauf.
Es ist ein bisschen unklar. Aber die Frage ist.
Was noch unklar ist, warum ist der Abfilter so rum? Also was ist denn das? Oder es ist hier breit, aber woher kommt dieser Strich dann? Aber wir reden schon wieder über Sachen, die unser Hörer nicht sehen können. Du musst es natürlich verlinken nachher.
Ich wollte eigentlich darauf hinaus. Ich meine, dass es im September neue MacBooks gibt, das denke ich mal relativ klar, weil das steht einfach mal an. Die Frage ist nur, was können die neu? Und ich denke, wenn so ein MacBook leichter wäre, leiser wäre, also vor allem kühler wäre, dass es nicht mehr so bläst.
Weil die Prozessoren, die werden zwar immer leistungsfähiger, aber ihre Hitze bleibt glaube ich relativ gleich dabei. Also was wir hinkriegen würden, ist, wenn du den Prozessor vom letzten Jahr, wenn sie den jetzt rausbringen würden, mit gleicher Performance wie im letzten Jahr, dann kriegen sie den vielleicht kühler hin, aber niemand will die gleiche Performance wie letztes Jahr. Alle wollen mehr Performance als letztes Jahr. Wobei ja, dieses Öko- oder Green-Computing ist ja gerade so ein bisschen angesagt, ne? Aber, naja...
Das klingt auch sehr nach Modewelle, oder?
Ja, das ist es ja immer alles, also... Aber ich glaub nicht, also kühler wird's nicht. Das interessiert einfach auch keinen. Wenn da steht irgendwie jetzt nur noch so und so viel Grad, also man hat ja noch nicht mal einen Vergleichswert, dann müsste man ja erstmal für die aktuellen Geräte eine Temperatur oder so eine Standardtemperatur einführen, damit sie die nächstes Jahr unterbieten können. So noch lohnt sich's ja gar nicht.
Also ich muss ja sagen, ich war jetzt für zwei Wochen war ich ja MacBook-Besitzer und nicht MacBook Pro-Besitzer, weil mein MacBook Pro in Reparatur war. Und ich muss ja sagen, ich bemitleide dich schon ein bisschen, Tim.
Mit so einem kleinen Rechner?
Ich bin sehr froh, doch einen MacBook Pro zu haben, muss ich sagen, so nach der Zeit.
Du bemitleidest mich?
Ja. Um diesen kleinen, langsam schwarzen Rechner. Langsam? Nein, langsam war er nur, weil er nur 2 GB RAM hatte.
Ja, die Performance ist identisch.
Die Performance ist identisch, aber ich finde, das Display ist es tatsächlich wert. Also wenn ihr überlegt, ob ihr euch...
Ich finde auch MacBook Pros genau...
Also ich habe es gestern wieder abholen können und ich sah es davor und mir kam das Display so unglaublich groß und hatte plötzlich so unglaublich viel Platz. Und dann ist es natürlich so, wenn man die Daten alle zurückgespielt hat, gerade von dem einen Rechner auf den anderen, dann sind die Fenster natürlich alle noch so groß wie auf dem MacBook und überall hatte ich plötzlich so einen schönen, großen Rand rumgeholt und ich konnte die Fenster endlich wieder auf Größe ziehen. MacBook Pro ist schon was Feines, auch wenn ich es wirklich sehr zu schätzen gewusst habe, wie schön leicht das ist, dieses latchlose Öffnen, also dieses, dass man nicht einen blöden Knopf drücken muss, damit die Klappe auffiert, ist großartig.
Ja, das ist einfach einstzwanzigstes Jahrhundertstand. Das MacBook Pro ist doch einfach mal all. Wie lange gibt es diesen Formfaktor jetzt? Sieben Jahre?
Sieben Jahre? Nein, sieben Jahre nicht. Ich weiß nicht, das iBook seit fünf Jahren. Ja, aber das Display ist es wert.
Du kannst die scheiß Festplatte nicht tauschen. Das ist einfach das Killer-Argument. Ich hab das ein paar Mal machen müssen, das ist einfach erniedrigend. Ich kauf doch keinen Apple-Computer, damit ich danach wie mit so einem Apfel im Maul die Hände mit einem Kabelbinder auf dem Rücken zusammengebunden, während ich noch von irgendeinem afrikanischen Sklaven ausgepeitscht werde, wirklich mich über meinen Rechner beugen muss und solche Qualen erleiden muss. Ich meine, da kann ich mir einen Dell kaufen. Da geht das wahrscheinlich einfacher.
Ich lass das vom Händler machen.
Ich lass das vom Händler machen, das ist doch erniedrigend, wenn man mal seine Platte rausnehmen muss. Kannst du auch schon fast heutzutage auch in kein Land mehr fahren, wo die nicht mittlerweile androhlen.
Bei Macbook Pro soll das jetzt voll einfach sein. Schrauben ab und dann hoch. Ist nicht mehr so wie früher. Machst du alle Schrauben ab und dann kannst du die Tastatur mit Dings hier so komplett hochheben. Ganz easy. Hab ich mir sagen lassen.
Hab ich mir sagen lassen?
Ich hab's noch nicht probiert, weil ich immer Angst hatte, dass es kompliziert hat, aber ist wohl nicht mehr. Das war bei den ersten Modellen so, das stimmt. Da musste man hier so komisches Zeug wegbiegen, aber inzwischen wohl kann man es einfach so hochheben.
Ach und wo sind da bitte die Schrauben?
Na hier so 40, 50, 100 Stück. Hier so auch mal.
40, 50 Schrauben?
Weiß ich nicht, nein. Hier sind vier hier und natürlich vier hier und hier sind keine. Und hinten sind wie viel? Nochmal zwei. Macht für mich nach Adam Riese zehn. Und unten vielleicht noch ein paar.
Ey, das ist doch scheiße.
Unten seh ich nochmal vier. 14 maximal.
Nur 14 Schrauben. Ey, Junge, ich löse hier drei Schrauben und die Sache ist gelritzt.
Oh, drei Schrauben anstatt 14. Schrauben ist Schrauben. LPU sagt Schrauben nicht.
Okay, ich hab nichts dagegen, wenn hier ein Mechanismus wieder reinkommt wie damals beim Pismo, wo du mal eben so ein Bügel ziehst, bloß das Problem war...
Und zwei Platten, äh Quatsch, zwei Batterien, das war Hammerfeature.
Ja gut, aber in dem Bügel bist du halt auch bei der normalen Arbeit häufiger mal rangekommen und hast halt mal so eben deine Festplatte oder dein Laufwerk oder dein Akku quer über den Tisch geschossen. Ja, selten? Was ist das für eine Aussage, selten? Also ich, ja, mir wird ja immer gnadenloses Apple-Fanboy-Tum unterstellt. Aber mal ehrlich, wenn dieser Laden nicht in der Lage ist, Hardware zu liefern, die einfach in jeder Hinsicht State-of-the-Art ist und vor allem kundenfreundlich ist, dann sind sie das Geld nie wert.
Aber normale Apple-User können ihre Festplatte gar nicht tauschen. Die wüssten nicht mehr, was sie sich für eine kaufen sollten.
Normale Apple-User, was soll denn das heißen?
Also ich für meinen Teil hatte noch nie das Bedürfnis. Also ich wünschte mir jetzt langsam eine größere Festplatte, aber die wär ich mir einfach...
Angenommen, du fährst in die USA. Du musst halt mal ganz schnell in die USA. Was machst du dann?
Festplatte ausbauen und dort wieder einbauen, weil sonst irgendwie die auf deinen Rechner gucken.
Naja, ich meine mittlerweile ist einfach eine Standardprozedur eine Grenze ist, dass sie halt auch einfach mal bei Interesse den ganzen Rechner mitnehmen. Und wenn du jetzt mal eben schnell einfach sicherstellen musst, dass sensible Daten nicht drin sind, dann kannst du natürlich jetzt anfangen, deine 180 GB Daten, die du hast, zu back-upen. Dann suchst du erst mal wohin. Das dauert dann wieder 8 Stunden, bricht dreimal irgendwie mit irgendeinem blöden Minus 32.540 Leer ab.
Und wie oft kommt es jetzt vor?
Das ist jetzt die Realität. Ja, ich hab das schon ein paar Mal gehabt. Ja, und es sind viele Länder. In Kanada fangen sie mit an, in Israel hast du das selbe Problem.
Also das ist wirklich eigentlich so...
Also wenn du in Israel ankommst und dein Laptop hat keine Festbettel, dann nehmen die die sowieso gleich fest.
Nein, der soll ja nicht keine Festbettel haben. Man schraubt da einfach eine nackte, leere Festbettel rein, die einfach unberührt ist. Und deine Daten sind einfach sicher zu Hause. Weil du brauchst halt nicht unbedingt immer alles unterwegs.
Aber das ist doch mal wieder der Beweis, was für unglaubliche Demokratien wir eigentlich leben, wo man...
Also du meinst, Apple sollte es jetzt leichter machen, an die Festbettel ran zu kommen, weil es so Länder wie Amerika und Israel und Kanada gibt. Und Pakistan zum Beispiel.
Ja, oder Kanada oder was auch immer. Ich meine, die werden demnächst einfach alle damit anfangen. Japan dreht ja auch schon frei. Das ist halt einfach ein Problem. Außerdem ist es eine elegante Methode, halt auch mal so offline Backup zu machen, wenn du irgendwie deinen Rechner zwar brauchst, aber nicht unbedingt mit den Daten...
Na ja, aber so schwer ist es nicht, glaube ich, mit dem Rechner aufzuschrauben. 14 Schrauben ist jetzt nicht so dolle Schlümpfe.
Das will ich erst mal sehen, dass das wirklich so ist.
Das kann ich ja irgendwann machen. Aber ich meine, du wechselst jetzt auch nicht irgendwie einmal im Jahr deine Platte, sondern eher so nach zwei Jahren oder so was. Wenn du deinen Laptop dann überhaupt noch hast und dann nicht sowieso ein größeres kaufen, mit schon der nächsten Platte.
Ich hab hier mehrere Festplatten liegen. Ich tausche schon mal auch meine Platte aus.
Du wechselst schon mal regelmäßig deine Festplatte auf?
Nicht regelmäßig, aber ich tue das halt. Und vor allem ich will halt...
Aber dafür hast du doch Firewire.
Wie hast du es denn mit deinem alten Kabel hergekommen?
Mit Firewire hast du einfach eine Bandbreite, wo der Wechsel effektiv Tage dauert. Stunden. Und wenn du diese Stunden dann gerade halt mal nicht hast, dann dauert es halt Tage. Ich hab schon so einen Prozess mit, ich müsste mal über Wochen hinausgeschoben, weil es einfach nicht instantan ging. Und weil ich auch keinen Bock hatte, meinen Rechner in alle kleine Details zu zerteilen.
Ich schlafe manchmal.
Furchtbar fand ich das. Ich finde das einfach beleidigend. Ihr könnt das schön reden, wie ihr wollt. Ihr seid einfach totale Apple-Fanboys. Aber ich finde das einfach mal scheiße. Das ist einfach mal nicht für den Kunden gedacht.
Tim gibt sich wirklich Mühe, so ein bisschen Kontra zu geben.
Ich finde das furchtbar.
Furchtbar, furchtbar, furchtbar.
Und beim MacBook stellt mich nur, dass es keine hintergrundbeleuchtete Tastatur ist.
Der Max hat seine ganzen Mathe schon leergesoffen.
Ich hab meine ganzen Mathe schon leergesoffen.
Echt? Ich hab frisch gekauft.
LED-Display-Hintergrundbeleuchtung ist eine großartige Sache.
Hast du doch schon, gibts doch schon.
Ich weiß, aber es hat das MacBook Pro im Gegensatz zum MacBook. Also ich probier jetzt nochmal ein bisschen die Unterschiede.
Aber optisch ist es jetzt nicht so der Unterschied und so viel Stromspann tut es auch nicht, oder?
Es ist heller, es ist heller. Mein Display ist einfach deutlich heller als dein Display.
Ja, das MacBook wird das demnächst auch haben.
Ah ja, ist ein bisschen heller.
Aber es ist halt doppelter Preis.
Ich meine, da hab ich schon über zwei MacBooks.
Es gibt so User, die kümmern sich einfach nicht irgendwie, was es so an neue, also wie sie ihre Rechner zum Beispiel aufrüsten können. Und wir reden jetzt mal von Laptops. Und ich berichte jetzt mal hier aus so einem Standard-Shop, so eine, was haben wir hier, 320 Gigabyte Platte kostet. Wie viel Euro, du darfst mal raten, Timme.
320er Platte für ein Laptop.
Ja, 2,5 Zoll, SATA.
Was hab ich zuletzt für meine, hab ich eigentlich mit 320er? Also ich würd sagen, die sind so auf 100 Euro?
Nee, 71.
Boah, das ist ein schöner Preis.
Genau, also weil immer Leute kümmern sich nicht oder haben von einem Jahr geguckt und da war es vielleicht noch das Doppelte oder das Dreifache. Inzwischen sind die Sachen echt in den Keller gerutscht.
Also eine Festplatte, eine größere will ich auch mal einbauen.
Welcher Hersteller? Das ist jetzt hier Samsung. Das ist aber auch grundsätzlich sind die...
Aber nicht verfügbar, wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder?
Nicht verfügbar, ja. Aber hier gibt es eine 250er, zum Beispiel 57 Euro oder hier eine andere 320, also auch nicht verfügbar. Guck einer an. Die 300er sind alle nicht verfügbar, doch hier. Für den 89er ist eine 320er verfügbar. Dann sind wir schon wieder ein bisschen teurer. Ist egal, die gibt es aber auf jeden Fall. Und das Gleiche muss ich nochmal erwähnen für Speicher fürs Laptop, weil ich habe auch schon überlegt, ob ich mal ein bisschen aufrüste. Und da habe ich letztens ein Gigabyte-Modul gesehen. Oder schon zwei Gigabyte-Module.
Nein, mit einem Gigabyte-Modul kommst du ja nicht weit.
Da komme ich nicht weit, weil das habe ich ja auch schon drin. Da brauche ich, glaube ich, DDR2. Und dann gibt es hier SODIMM. Und dann klicken wir mal hier. Tim, der Netz ist zu langsam. Klicken wir mal hier. Und dann gibt es hier zwei Gigabyte-Module fürs Laptop für 32 Euro. Das heißt, man kann für 65 Euro oder so seinen Laptop auf 4 Gigabyte bringen. Und dann hat man sogar noch die 2x 1 Gigabyte-Module übrig und kann die seinem Junior schenken oder so. Oder wem auch immer selbstbedürftig ist.
Oder einen praktischen Rückenkratzer draus bauen. Ich habe hier noch diesen ASUS dabei, diesen EPC, den Tim jetzt mal haben wollte für irgendwas, um das auszuprobieren. Und da habe ich 1 Gigabyte eingebaut aus meinem MacBook Pro, was ich übrig hatte.
Weil sonst wird man immer schwer seine kleinen Module los. Wieso den gleichen Speicher kannst du ja auch nicht? Die haben halt unterschiedliche Produkte bei Apple, damit jeder sich so sein Ding aussuchen kann, was er so gerne hätte. Und dass man nie 100%ig alles trifft, das geht auch gar nicht.
Ich wollte nicht so direkt... Also es ist jetzt schön, dass es geklappt hat, aber ich wollte jetzt nicht direkt so einen Streit lostreten. Ich bin ja mal so ein bisschen am Überlegen, weil ich mag ja das gerade schwarze MacBook, mag ich eigentlich schon ganz gerne. Ich fand die Tastatur immer ganz hübsch. Ich finde es vom Design her um einiges schicker als das MacBook Pro. Und habe es jetzt mal zwei Wochen gehabt und habe eben festgestellt, nee, ich bin schon ganz glücklich mit meinem MacBook Pro. Mehr wollte ich ja gar nicht sagen.
Beide zu schwer. So ein R ist schon toll.
Das R ist schon schick auf jeden Fall, aber das R ist, ich glaube, es ist in der Praxis noch relativ limitiert. Also ich kenne ja nur ein paar Leute, die das haben und die eigentlich keine hohen Ansprüche haben an die Rechenleistung und sowas. Aber was ich höre, ist, dass der W-Lane-Empfang ziemlich scheiße sein soll. Was natürlich gerade für einen MacBook Air eigentlich doch ziemlich peinlich ist.
Ein Spruch.
Der Zeuge beruft sie auf höherem Sagen.
Und dass ein Prozessor regelmäßig mal aussteigt. Also der hat ja zwei Kerne drinne und wenn er zu heiß wird, dann schaltet er einen Kern ab und das soll wohl deutlich zu häufig passieren. Dass plötzlich mittendrin ein Kern von so einem MacBook Air ausgeht. Also insofern fürchte ich so richtig, also das wird noch ein Produktzyklus oder sowas da sein, bis das wirklich ein schönes Gerät ist, glaube ich.
Also worauf ich ja gespannt bin, wenn es bei der nächsten Computergeneration ist, denn ich denke mal, wenn jetzt ein MacBook Pro oder MacBook neu rauskommt, dass sie auch da dann so SSD, also dieses Solid State Disk, also Flash-Speicher irgendwie anbieten. Und wie denn da die Preise sind, weil wir hatten ja schon berichtet, dass bei MacBook Air ist der Preis runtergegangen von dem Flash-Speicher, von gar nicht so unerheblich. 500 Euro oder Dollar. Ja, und wenn neue MacBook Pros oder MacBooks halt irgendwie kommen, wird mich auch mal da interessieren, was das für Preise sind, weil das ist schon cool.
Also da würde ich vorher erstmal gerne Benchmarks sehen, was das überhaupt bringt und wie hoch die Stromersparnis wirklich ist und sowas, bevor ich dafür Geld aus dem Fenster werfe.
Na ja, aber das heißt Stromersparnis...
Ich muss ja mein Zufrieden sein.
Sagen wir mal, es ist kein Stromersparnis da, aber es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so warm wie eine Platte. Es ist weniger laut als eine Platte. Es ist in der Latenz von einer Zugriffszeit schneller als eine Festplatte.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Dauertransferrate angeht.
Aber wann braucht man die? Hauptsächlich ist doch dein Rechnerarm random lesen und das ist genau da, wo diese Flash-Dinger schnell sind.
Also ich will erstmal ein paar Real-World Benchmarks sehen, bevor ich...
Also ich glaube, ich bin schon überzeugt. Also es wäre mir vielleicht noch zu teuer. Weil es ist halt gerade noch so ein neuer Shit, da ist es immer teuer. Das würde mich vielleicht noch abhalten, aber so von den technischen Geschichten bin ich schon voll überzeugt.
Gut, machen wir vielleicht mal Schluss hier mit der Glaskugel, das ist ja auch immer alles so ein bisschen, was man so haben will und so. Wir müssen halt gucken, was kommt. Wo sieht es aus? Tja, was ist denn gekommen? Neulich gab es ein HP Printer Driver Software Update. Über Software Update.
Das war doch Lexmark.
Jetzt komm ich mir aber so ein bisschen vor, wie damals in der Travi-Werbung.
Ich hab ein HP Driver Update bekommen.
Aber Lexmark da auch, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ist egal. Und weiter, das ist halt noch nicht passiert, dass ein Drittersteller über das Apple Software Update seine Updates einspielen darf.
Aber das sind ja die Treiber, die mitgeliefert wurden mit dem Betriebssystem.
Genau. Trotzdem gab es das noch nicht. Also ich meine, sie liefern zwar Treiber mit, aber sie haben bisher noch nie Updates geliefert. Sie sagen natürlich mal wieder nicht, was eigentlich da geupdatet wurde und ob mich das jetzt irgendwie betrifft und ob das auch...
Ich würde auch klar sagen, es ist Bugfixes und Better Performance. Manchmal sogar nur Bugfixes.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was dabei stand, aber auf jeden Fall nichts wirklich Sinnvolles. Dazu kommt der HP-Drucker, den ich hier verwende, den ich übrigens auch eingeschränkt empfehlen kann. Der brauchte dann schon nochmal sein eigenes Treiberpaket, was dann allerdings auch erst ein dreiviertel Jahr nach Leopard-Release auch in einer aktualisierten Version für Leopard vorlag, sodass man wieder alle Features nutzen kann.
Sag mal, hast du das bei diesem Drucker eigentlich... Das ist ja so ein All-in-one-Kann-alles-Fax-Scanner.
Genau, sollen wir gleich mal sagen.
Tim, das hatten wir schon mal in meiner Sendung.
Hatten wir schon mal? Hast du das hingekriegt, dass du...
Ich kann trotzdem sagen, was es ist. HP LaserJet 3055.
Kann der Netzwerk? Kannst du den so programmieren, dass er einen Fax empfängt und das dann einfach per E-Mail weiterleitet?
Ja.
Das geht?
Das benutze ich allerdings noch nicht. Kann er aber angeblich. Aber ich habe nicht so richtig Bock, irgendwie E-Mail-Settings auf meinem Drucker. Das ist nicht so der Ort, wo ich das haben will.
Also ich hatte neulich mal, wir hatten die Notwendigkeit im Büro, weil niemand im Büro ist, dass wir die Faxe nicht ausdrucken konnten, sondern einfach die per Mail weiterleiten mussten. Und ich habe diesen blöden Drucker, um zu verricken. Also es ist ein anderes Modell, aber auch so Scanner, alles kann alles und kann auch irgendwas per Web-Interface scanen und so was. Aber einfach, dass man irgendwo eine Einstellung hat, wo man sagen kann, du schick mir doch dieses blöde Fax einfach als PDF zu und gut. Die gab es nicht.
Genau das Problem hatte ich neulich auch.
Und du hast noch eine Lösung angeboten, die mir dann sehr viel weitergeholfen hat.
Ach, hast du die auch geklickt?
Ich hab, du willst jetzt auf MacBay hinaus?
Darauf bin ich hinaus. Wurde mir zugezwittert und ich hab halt auf Twitter gefragt und dann kamen halt gleich ein paar interessante Hinweise und MacBay gefiel mir dann so am besten. MacBay ist so ne Art.Mac für die Realität oder so.
Kann das ja nicht mit macnews.de irgendwie zusammenhängen oder irgendwie sowas?
Das kann sein, ich weiß gar nicht, was dahinter ist. Ich sag das jetzt auch ganz wertbefreit. Auf jeden Fall bieten sie halt, wenn man sich da jetzt kostenlos registriert, sozusagen mit ihrem kostenlosen Basic-Account, bieten sie dir eben schon mal einen Fax-Dienst an. Das heißt, du kriegst eine Telefonnummer und kannst darüber Faxe empfangen und du kannst aber auch Faxe senden. Direkt über den Druckerdialog? Ja, direkt über den Druckerdialog und hier kommt jetzt der Twist. Es ist ja mittlerweile so, dass der Leopard ja schon zwischen Faxen und Druckern unterscheidet. Mein Happy LaserJet zum Beispiel ist sowohl als Drucker als auch als Fax im System vorrätig. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Druckdialog aufmache, dann gibt es ja links unten diese User-Interface-Verballhornung, da dieser Button mit dem Dreieck drauf. Die einzige Stelle im ganzen OS, wo sie so einen Scheiß machen. Dann kann man da so... Das wüsste ich nicht wo. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen schäbig. Dann geht man da auf jeden Fall drauf und sagt irgendwie Fax PDF. Das ist ja auch furchtbar finde ich. Warum gibt es nicht Apfel-Shift-Alt-P oder so für Faxen oder was weiß ich. Irgendwas. Anyway, dann kannst du halt einen Fax auswählen und dann hast du dafür eben auch einen Dialog. Das heißt, in diesem Dialog kannst du Coverpage machen, kannst die Telefonnummer eingeben. Das Problem dabei ist, der kommt mit internationalen Telefonnummern nicht klar, wenn du da irgendwie so plus 4.9 eingibst und so weiter, ist irgendwie alles im Eimer. Wie MacBay das jetzt macht, ist, die bieten dir ein Software-Paket, das du halt installierst. Da sind so allerlei Treiber dann sozusagen für ihren Fax-Dienst drin. Allerdings installiert sich das nicht als Fax, sondern nur als Drucker. Was erstmal kein Problem ist, d.h. du wählst es aus als Drucker, du druckst dann dahin und dann gibt es irgendwie so ein Callback, d.h. wenn dann der Druckjob abgespult ist und er sozusagen druckt, dann wird eine spezielle Applikation, so eine MacBay-Fax-Hilfsprogramm, Schnickes-Programm gestartet, wo du dann halt die Rufnummer eingibst. Vorteil ist, du umgehst so diese Probleme, die der Standarddruckdialog hat. Nachteil ist halt natürlich irgendwie, mein Gott, wenn es eh schon so einen Hook für Faxe gibt, warum nicht den benutzen, so keine Ahnung, warum sie das jetzt nicht gemacht haben, wird sicherlich irgendwelche Gründe haben, weil sie da mehr Flexibilität haben, pipa po, und da irgendwie online auch gleich die Möglichkeit haben zu checken, weil es kostet natürlich dann auch Geld, wenn du Faxe verschickst, dann musst du so Credits irgendwie verbrauchen und ein Credit ist irgendwie sowas wie 5 Cent. Also dich kostet sozusagen ein versinnertes Fax de facto 5 Cent.
Nee, ich glaube, wie viel das kostet, es kann auch mehrere Credits kosten.
Es kann auch mehrere Credits kosten, aber bisher war es so, dass jedes Fax 1 gekostet hat. Unklar, auch die, wo er mir gesagt hat, dass es eigentlich nichts kostet, kosteten dann auch 1.
Und man kriegt irgendwie 50 da geschenkt, habe ich mitbekommen?
Nee, 5.
5, okay, dann waren es nur 5.
Jaja, also man kriegt nicht viel geschenkt, aber soweit funktioniert es ganz gut, und wenn man halt ein Fax empfängt, dann kriegt man es einfach per E-Mail und dann eben als PDF.
Das war relativ simpel, also man kriegt da so eine 018-Nummer.
Genau.
Und die kostet irgendwie, war auch mal 9 Cent pro Minute oder so was. Und wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt so eine 018-Nummer nach draußen geben will, dann muss man sich halt eine Rufumleitung einrichten, irgendwie in einer Telefonanlage.
Nee, die 018-Nummer ist kostenlos, und wenn du eine spezielle 030-Nummer haben willst, dafür musst du dann nochmal bezahlen.
Nee, ich meine, es kostet 9 Cent pro Minute an, diese 018-Nummer in den Fax zu schicken.
Achso, andere Leute?
Genau, also wenn ich da einen Fax schicke, und ich hab das eben per Anrufweiterleitung dann einfach eingerichtet. Ich hab unsere 030-Nummer genommen, die wir schon hatten, und hab dann einfach einen Anrufweiterleitung auf diese Nummer gemacht, und dann bezahle ich jetzt einfach pro Fax, was wir empfangen, bezahle ich so und so viel Geld.
Ich finde, wenn Leute mir einen Fax schicken wollen, wenn sie unbedingt darauf bestehen, das über diesen vorsinnflutlichen Dienst zu machen, dann können sie auch dafür bezahlen.
Ihr wisst, dass man ja auch mit so einem Rechner, der noch so einen Moderm oder Telefonanschluss hat, auch da so einen Fax-Server starten kann. Built-in bei US-10. Gibt es auch noch. Und dann kann man sogar mit, wenn man noch eine alte Kiste an die Telefonleitung sich zu Hause anschließt, kann man der Fax-Sharing einschalten. Dann kann man von seinem Laptop, auch wenn die aktuellen Geräte jetzt keinen Modermanschluss mehr haben, kann man über den anderen Rechner dann da Faxe verschicken und empfangen. Man braucht nicht mal MacRest 10 Server, sondern so ein normales MacRest reicht dafür.
Aber man muss halt dann trotzdem immer wieder einen Rechner haben, der dafür übrig ist. Ich hab das auch ein paar Mal versucht, aber im Zweifelsfall läuft der dann halt immer nicht, oder der Rechner ist nicht stabil genug. Faxe ist halt so was, ich meine, wenn du wirklich jemanden eine Fax-Nummer gibst, wo er dir dann was faxt, dann willst du eigentlich auch wirklich einen halbwegs zuverlässigen Dienst haben. Das übernimmt bei mir jetzt halt dieser Laserjet, der ist halt immer an, das ist halt der Nachteil. Aber zumindest kommen da halt Faxe an und werden gleich ausgedruckt und theoretisch kann er sie halt auch weiter mehlen.
Wie gesagt, für die anderen Fälle sind diese 018-Nummern echt super. Also das hat so auf Anhieb funktioniert.
Ja, ich hab jetzt den Rest nicht so getestet bei MacBay, war ganz überrascht. Also die bieten halt auch irgendwie Sinking-Dienste und File-Sharing und Peepapo an.
Das sieht alles ganz gut aus.
Keine Ahnung. Also falls da jemand Erfahrung hat mit MacBay, so würden wir da ganz gerne in den Kommentaren nochmal was zu hören. Vielleicht ist das ja nochmal wert, dass man sich das nochmal anschaut. Ja stimmt, da oben steht irgendwie mcnews.de, also das hat wohl irgendwas damit zu tun, was auch immer. Gut, damit können wir das glaube ich auch zu den Akten legen, oder? Also ich benutze das jetzt erstmal soweit, wenn Leute mir halt unbedingt Faxe schicken wollen, gebe ich ihnen diese unglaublich lange Telefonnummer. Und dann habe ich zumindest den Kram.
In den Kommentaren kam noch so eine schöne Frage, und zwar, wie man iTerm entsorgen kann am besten? Also die Frage war eigentlich...
Also die Frage war eigentlich, hat er nicht immer eine Alternative gesucht?
Ja, er hat...
Achso, das meinste damit.
Das meinte ich mit iTerm.
Ich bin ja ganz zufrieden mit Terminate. Seitdem das Taps hat?
Ich hab auch... Genau das wollte ich empfehlen. Also ich nutze auch noch iTerm. Ich hab genau das gleiche Problem, was er auch hat, dass es immer beim Beenden abstürzt und auch irgendwann unglaublich viel Arbeitsspeicher braucht.
Ist das überhaupt schon Universal Binary oder was?
Ja, Universal müsste ich sagen.
Weil er meint, dass es nicht gepflegt wurde.
Ja, die sind leider ein bisschen hinterher. Vermutlich auch aufgrund dessen, dass Universal ist. Aber das hängt ein bisschen rum, leider. Und ich benutze ja auch das Terminal wirklich den ganzen Tag über. Und ich bin seit Monaten am Versuchen, endlich mal umzusteigen. Und das Problem ist, dass in iTerminal ist wirklich eine hübsche Bookmark-Verwaltung drin. Mit der man mal eben, also ich verbinde mich sehr, sehr viel mit anderen, mit irgendwelchen wilden Servern da draußen und wo man sich dann SSH-Befehl abspeichert und dann ist man drauf auf dem Ding. Das geht mit Terminal auch, aber nicht ganz so komfortabel. Aber vielleicht nochmal dazu erklären, wie es geht, weil...
Aber ich meine, wenn dir dein Terminal abstürzt und dann alle Sessions weg sind, dann das wär mir ja nix. Wenn du mehrere Fenster offen hast, die sind ja alle mit weg. Dann richtig.
Die sind alle mit weg.
Also stürzt, das darf nicht passieren.
Das geht gar nicht ab. Und man kann das irgendwie, wie geht das jetzt? Also man kann das auch abspeichern, so eine Session nämlich. Und zwar, indem man dann sagt, mit Einstellungen exportieren, glaube ich. Und wenn man das dann abspeichert im Application Support slash Terminal. Na du solltest jetzt eigentlich besser drin sein, Terminal-Benutzer hier. Ich bin ja noch Iterm-Benutzer.
Ich hausche dir einfach.
Dann kann man da...
Ach du meinst beim Terminal kann man das machen? Ja klar.
Genau, dann kann man deine Einstellungen abspeichern. Muss man noch sagen, wo stellt man hier das Startprogramm ein?
Ich hab's bei Leopard ein bisschen geändert. Vorher hab ich's auch benutzt, aber mit Leopard haben sie sowieso komisch umgestellt. Da hab ich's seitdem benutzt, ich irgendwie nicht mehr, ich weiß auch nicht. Was hast du umgestellt? Na vorher hatte ich so Art Favorites, wo ich mich mit SSH hinconnecten will. Also ich hab immer das SSH-Kommando benutzt, als auszufühlenes Kommando. Man hätte ja auch was anderes nehmen können, aber ich wollte irgendwo hinconnecten und hab mir dann Terminals gemacht, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel auf den Arbeitsrechner gehe, auf die Feierwoll, dass mein Hintergrund rot ist, dass ich weiß, hier jetzt bloß keinen Scheiß machen und dass wenn ich nach Hause komme, ist irgendwie der Hintergrund grün, dass ich weiß, ich kann hier rumbasseln, wie ich will und so ne Sachen. Und mit Leopard haben sie irgendwie ihr Profile, Geschichten so umgestellt, dass es mir zu umständlich war, es zu benutzen oder ich hatte keinen Bock, alles umzustellen, weiß nicht, wenn ich es benutze, ist es irgendwie nicht mehr. Hab wieder aufgehört, so spannend war auch nicht.
Aber es ist doch, warte mal.
Aber lange Rede kurzer Sinn, du hast keine Alternative für den Menschen, der eine i-Term-Alternative haben will.
Also mir ist da auch nichts eingefallen.
Ich kenne auch gar keine. Also ich kenne i-Terms nicht, ich habe es mir gar nicht angeguckt.
Außer eben dem Terminal. Man kann ja einfach in Einstellungen gehen. Da hat man hier verschiedene Profile. Das sieht schon ein bisschen bookmarkig aus. Da kann man dann auch für jede einstellen, welcher Befehl beim Start ausgeführt werden soll.
Das ist bei i-Term oder beim Terminal?
Das ist mir zu viel und zu groß da alles schon zum Rumstellen. Das ging vorher ein bisschen leichter. Da konnte man besser verwalten. Hier ist der Pro-Einstellung nochmal ein Unterkategorie, wo man Texten, Farben und Zeug einstellt. Das war vorher ein bisschen zusammengefasst. Das ist schon wieder zu viel für mich.
Aber es funktioniert wie ein Eins. Tada, da bin ich. Ja, also das Terminal man verwenden anstelle von i-Term, das ist die Bookmark-Verwaltung. Sie kommt nicht so rausgefahren oder sowas. Aber man kann die relativ einfach öffnen. Und dann kann die auch, glaube ich, im Doppelklick, indem man in der Library, Application Support, wo die drin liegt, Library... Da kann man die auch per Doppelklick öffnen, sodass man die sich auch zum Beispiel entweder in einem Ordner, den man einfach ins Doc packen kann, oder die Verbindung zu den Servern, zum Beispiel mit dem Ordner packen kann, der von Launchbar untersucht wird, kann dann darüber die... Ja super, Terminal ist natürlich nicht drin... .und kann dann darüber einstellen, dass die Verbindungen öffnen zum Server, dann geht es auch relativ komfortabel, ohne dass man sich über die Menüleister hucken muss. Prinzip verstanden? Oder habe ich mich gerade zu kryptisch ausgedrückt?
Ja, für mich schon, aber ich habe auch noch halb hingehört, weil ich noch mal geschaut habe, was ihr noch für... Ich werde hier gerade so ein bisschen betwittert, aber vor allem habe ich noch mal in die Kommentare von der letzten Sendung geschaut, ob da noch ein paar Fragen sind. Und da fiel mir gerade auf... Darf ich... weiter? Ja, ne? Na ja, jetzt kam mir mal wieder diese leidige Ogg-Diskussion auf. Aber du hast ja da geantwortet, Max.
Da war ich ein bisschen pissig. Echt? Ich war nicht ganz so böse gemeint, wie es vielleicht drüber kam.
Ach nö, aber ich fand einfach deine Energie da ganz interessant. Du hast wirklich die Top 25 bei Amazon, der meist verkauften MP3-Player, durchgeklickt und mal geschaut, wer was unterstützt.
Das ging relativ flott, ja. Ich hab jetzt nicht mir die Handbücher der entsprechenden Geräte runtergeladen.
Sondern was bei Amazon?
Ich war auf der Amazon-Seite und hab gedacht, wenn da jemand Ogg hat, dann wird er damit werben. Oder wird er zumindest bei den unterstützten Audioformaten mit reinschreiben. Und da die meisten hatten MP3, WMA und das wars. Und nicht mal M4A. Insofern gehe ich mal davon aus, dass die wirklich Ogg noch nie gehört haben.
Ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Es gibt halt immer diesen Ruf nach Freiheit. Und angeblich soll Ogg das dann besser machen. Ich bin da nicht so von überzeugt. Ich setze da eher darauf, dass MP3 das Patent demnächst ausläuft.
Also es wäre sicherlich nicht schlecht, wenn das iPhone oder entsprechende Geräte das von vornherein unterstützen würden. Aber ich kenne persönlich niemanden, den es stört, das es nicht tun.
Ich kenne Leute, die das stört. Also in der Praxis stört. Die Diskussion haben wir nun schon mehrfach gehabt, glaube ich. Haben wir die auch schon mal hier gehabt?
Ja, die hatten wir auch schon hier.
Ich will dir auch noch mal zum Besten geben, dass die Kompression von Musik schon interessant ist, aber diese verlustbehaftete Kompression ist eigentlich nicht mehr interessant. Weil schon seit Jahren, seit 22 Jahren, oder ich weiß nicht, wie lange gibt es CDs? Seit 1982, glaube ich, gibt es jetzt digitale Musik auf CDs, ist die Qualität ja nicht besser geworden. Wir haben irgendwie 16 Bit bei 44,1 Kilohertz und es ist seit 1982 so. Und die könnte man inzwischen ja auch ohne Verluste komprimieren. Dann kommt man so auf ca. die Hälfte. Da gibt es ja diesen Apple Lossless, da gibt es irgendwie den Flag-Encoder. Dann gibt es, glaube ich, noch irgendwie so ein paar Formate, die das Lossless machen. Und da die Qualität der CDs ja nicht besser wird, also die Daten werden ja nicht mehr so wie es bei Filmen gibt, gibt es ja jetzt DVD, dann gab es Bruder, das wird immer mehr an Daten, da braucht man weiterhin ordentliche Komprimierer und die sind halt verlustbehaftet. Aber Musik bräuchten wir eigentlich gar nicht. Und ich würde mal sagen, wenn man einfach jetzt anfängt, Lossless zu komprimieren, dann hat man diese ganze Diskussion gar nicht mehr.
Aber warum?
Na, weil es dann super klingt, man keine Verluste hat. Das Original, das geht nicht um, was ich höre. Natürlich geht es doch um, was du hörst.
Ich meine, es geht doch darum, höre ich einen Unterschied zwischen verlustbehafter Komprimierung oder nicht.
Was mich stört ist, ich mach meiner Mama irgendwie, okay, vielleicht nicht erlaubt, aber ich mache ja nur Kopie von einer CD und hab die gekauft im Apple-Shop, sagen wir mal, macht meiner Mama irgendwie eine CD draus, das heißt, es wird irgendwie endecoded, kommt auf die CD. Meine Mama denkt, es ist ja gar nicht so schlecht, das will ich auf meinem iPod haben und ribbt sich die CD wieder. Und dann ist es irgendwie, hast du es schon zweimal komprimiert, dann wird es noch schlechter. Also immer dieses Formatwechsel hin und her, mit jedem Komprimieren wird es ein Stück schlechter und das hättest du bei verlustfreier Komprimierung nicht.
Aber dafür habe ich bei einer verlustbehafteten Komprimierung den Vorteil, dass mehr draufpasst.
Ja, aber das würde ich dem nicht so einholen. Das ist ja bei den Rechnern jetzt schon. Und womit ribben die meist Leute mit 256 Kilobit oder so? Also verlustfrei ist auch nur bei 700 oder so was.
Das gilt aber jetzt alles nur für Musik. Bei Podcasts, wenn du nur Sprache hast, ist eine Kompression durchaus sinnvoll, weil da kannst du wirklich so viel sinnlose Daten vernichten. Und vor allem bei Downloads muss man halt auch sehen, das verbraucht halt Bandbreite.
Aber es sind 3, 4, 5 Jahre, da interessiert das alles niemanden mehr.
Naja, ich meine für einen Podcaster ist das ein echtes Thema, weil das halt auch was mit Geld und Plattenplatz und so weiter zu tun hat. Also du musst sowohl für das Vorrätech halten, irgendwie letzten Endes Geld zahlen. Weil das muss ja auch irgendwo gespeichert werden. Das ist bei Video noch jetzt ein größeres Thema, glaube ich, als bei Audio. Aber am Ende hängt es davon ab, wieviel du wirklich anbietest. Und auch Leute, die jetzt so mit dem iPhone oder so rumrennen und ein Podcast da drauf haben, da ist das schon relevant. Also guck mal, wenn ich jetzt hier, ich bin jetzt übrigens mit der Kompression runtergegangen. Also ich habe vorher mal 128 Kilobit gemacht, Mobile Max und auch CRE mache ich jetzt halt auf 96. Das ist immer noch recht üppig, aber ich mag halt einfach Artefakte nicht. Aber ich höre halt bei 96 jetzt nichts. Also ich höre nichts, weiß nicht. Ich habe jetzt auch bisher noch nicht gehört, dass irgendjemand Artefakte gehört. Aber wenn man noch weiter runtergehen würde, wird es dann schon schlecht. Und dann hast du irgendwann diese Warbereffekte, wie das bei manchen Podcasts halt ist, die jetzt wirklich gnadenlos da auf Bandbreite sparen, runteroptimieren. So, da muss man schon irgendwie seinen Punkt finden. Aber wenn man jetzt einen Podcast abonniert hat und man hört da mal so zehn Ausgaben nicht und die liegen dann aber alle immer noch so rum.
Das ist richtig mit Datenmast, die da auftreten.
Ja, dann sind es dann halt bei so langen Podcasts, die eben schlecht komprimiert sind, dann liegt da halt mal so ein Gigabyte rum. So, und Gigabyte ist halt schon so ein Achtel von so schnellen Einfragen.
Also schlecht komprimiert heißt in groß.
Genau, also im schlechten Sinne von groß.
Also ich hab ja recht, aber ich glaub, in den nächsten paar Jahren eine 1TB-Platte ist jetzt bei 100 Euro.
Ich red aber von heute. Heute hast du einfach dieses Problem.
Ja, aber weil du meinst, du wartest bis MP3 demnächst mal die Lizenzpreis. Aber ich glaube, das wird... Also es ist ja auch bald erst irgendwann und ich denke mal irgendwann...
Ja, aber MP3 löst das Problem ja schon heute. So, das komprimiert aber. Du meintest ja, man muss ja irgendwie lossless machen. Aber jetzt Podcast-Lossless zu entkoden, das wäre ein bisschen... Das ist wirklich blödsinnig.
Also ich für meinen Teil muss sagen, also bei einem Podcast wär's wirklich albern und auch bei Musik, also ich meine die Kopfhörer, also ich glaube nicht, dass ich meine Ohren so gut...
Es geht mir gar nicht um Qualität.
Warum dann?
Warum nicht? Weil ich gerne zusammen packe und danach raus packe und dann hab ich wieder das Gleiche.
Ja, das ist...
Und dann brauchst du ja auch keine Sorgen, man braucht ja auch nicht wundern, ist das Rauschen jetzt, weil jetzt doch einer nicht so richtig gut entkodet hat oder... Also weil manchmal hörst du nämlich schon was. So wie Tim ja meinte, wenn es manchmal warbert und zischt und rauscht und sonst wie.
Ja, aber dafür muss ich mir Sorgen darum machen, dass ich plötzlich auf meinem iPhone nur noch drei Musikstücke draufkriege.
Du musst dir da bald keine Sorgen mehr machen.
Also, dass Flash-Speicher günstig wird, das wollen wir erstmal sehen.
Gut, wollen wir mal ein bisschen vorspulen und mal zu unserer Apple is Evil-Sektion kommen. Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit der Black Hat?
Ja, nee, das hast du nicht gelesen heute?
Nee, heute hab ich es nicht gelesen.
Gab's gar keinen Vortrag, der für über Apple gehalten werden sollte.
Von Apple oder über Apple?
Also Black Hat hat gesagt, den Vortrag hätte es gar nicht geben sollen. Er wurde nicht gestrichen, das gab's ihm sowieso nie.
Den über Feil wollt? Ja. Und wo kommt das Gerücht her, dass Apple den unterbunden hat?
Ich hab's vorhin noch gelesen, es gibt so einen Typen, der heißt Edge mit Nachnamen. Das ist wohl sein richtiger Name sogar. Und man hatte wohl vermutet, dass er diesen Vortrag einreicht. Oder er hat angekündigt, so was einreichen zu wollen, aber er hat das nie getan.
Jetzt heißt das wunderschön. Schauen wir mal kurz den Kontext erklären. Die ursprüngliche Meldung war, dass Apple angeblich dagegen vorgegangen wäre, dass ein Vortrag über eine Feilvolt-Lücke auf der Black Hat Hacker-Konferenz gehalten werden sollte. Das war eh schon ein bisschen fishy, weil das erste, was ich gelesen habe, war dann so, dass der Typ irgendwie unter NDA ist. Und mit Apple in irgendeiner Form deswegen eigentlich gar nichts hätte sagen dürfen. Und da wurde dann auch noch behauptet, dass Apple auch selbst einen Vortrag auf der Black Hat halten wollte und den zurückgezogen hätte. Stimmt das dann auch nicht?
Das zweite war, dass Apple Security Researcher da so einen Forumstalk halten sollten, also so ein Diskussionsding ins. Und das wurde aber vom Moderator zurückgezogen. Und das steht auch noch in dem gedruckten Programmheftchen von Black Hat. Also da haben sie es nicht wieder rausgekriegt schnell genug. Da ist es immer noch drin, woanders ist es gestrichen. Da weiß ich nicht, ob dieser Moderator, der sich da zurückgezogen hat, ob das auch schon einer von Apple war oder nicht. Es kann sein, dass der auch nicht mal von Apple ist. Also das ist alles, ich denke mal...
Man wartet mal besser ab, bis die Black Hat gelaufen ist. Dann weiß man auch was machen.
Und dann könnte es sein, dass natürlich alle gerne jetzt auf Apple rumprügeln wollen, was ja auch immer eine prima Sache ist. Machen wir ja auch den ganzen Tag. Aber dass vielleicht dort ein bisschen zu früh losgekloppt wurde, bevor richtig die Fakten irgendwie auf den Tisch lagen. Da kann ich mir natürlich schon vorstellen, dass irgendwie alle dachten, der reicht hier diesen Pfeil-Vault-Vortrag ein, hat es nicht gemacht. Dann dachten sie gleich, Apple hätte mit zu tun. Vielleicht haben die ja sogar damit zu tun und vielleicht hat er deswegen nichts Weiteres eingereicht, weil sie es schon vorher herausgefunden haben. Es kann ja sein, werden wir aber wohl nie rausfinden, weil auch das wird Apple ja nie zugeben, wenn sie den schon vorher hinkriegen, dass er seinen Talk nicht einreicht.
Also... Apple's Evilness.
Heise hat gemeldet.
Wir hatten doch hier Chaos Computer Club Kongress, also Chaos Kongress gab es doch auch. Wie heißt der?
Chaos Communication Kongress.
Ah, der 24-10-3, der letzte.
Ja.
So, und da war doch, oder war schon der Vorletz, ich weiß gar nicht, auch irgendwie bei FileVault auch ein Talk, richtig?
Und gab es denn von der Person, die du ja auch gut kennst, Anzeichen, dass Apple versucht hat, den zu unterbinden?
Nein. Also soweit ich weiß nicht.
Weil das hätten sie ja dann probiert.
23C3. Check das Apple-Baum, meinst du, oder?
War nicht das auch von Angelo irgendwas? Da gab es doch auch schon mal was von Angelo mit irgendwie Mach-O, irgendwie exploiten, noch ein bisschen älter. Die war aber eigentlich auch schon bekannt, das stimmt schon. Aber wir haben da noch nichts gehört von unserem Kongress, dass Apple mal versucht hat, irgendwas zu unterbinden.
Nein, gar nicht. Das glaube ich auch nicht, dass sie das tun würden.
Bei uns probieren würden?
Ja, oder dass sie auch nur irgendeine Chance hätten. Sowas machen wir nicht. Also ich meine, wir haben ja noch den Vorteil, dass bei uns nicht die Polizei anrückt und Leute von der Bühne wegnimmt, so wie auf der Black Hat schon das passiert ist. Ich hoffe auch nicht, dass wir da hinkommen.
Das wäre mal ein cooler Stunt.
Es gibt Presse. Ja, aber trotzdem ist das nicht so schön. Ja gut, aber das sind halt meistens so Sachen, die mit Copyright Act und so weiter zu tun haben. Das sind halt so Sachen, die Digital, PIN, Millennium, Copyright Act. So harte Reglementierung, denke ich mal, wenn wir hier auch auf absehbare Zeiten nicht bekommen. Aber ich will es mal nicht an die Wand schreiben, weil sonst ist es morgen gleich wahr. So, was habe ich noch gelesen? Ich habe gelesen, dass Apple bald mehr Bargeld als Microsoft hat. Angeblich.
Analyst behauptet.
Hat ein Analyst behauptet, was natürlich auch nicht viel heißt. Aber dass sie viel Bargeld haben, das ist ja schon lange bekannt.
21 Milliarden.
23,7 Milliarden haben sie angeblich schon. Und so, wie sich das derzeit entwickelt, sei das wohl möglich, dass es 40 Milliarden sein und das sei ja dann mehr als. Microsoft hat 23,7. Ich habe es verdreht. 20,8 hat Apple.
20,8. Also die Postbank hat mir gerade geschickt, dass ich 0,525 Prozent kriegen würde. Und dann können wir ja mal kurz auseinen, wenn ihr zur Postbank geht.
Festgeld?
5,25. Ja, Festgeld. Ab 200.000 Euro. 20,8 Milliarden ist ja schon ein bisschen mehr als 200.000 Euro Festgeld.
Die machen auch bestimmt mehr als 5,5.
Und dann kriegen die... Gott, jetzt muss ich ja Nullen ranpacken.
Hast du das letzte Mal schon ausgerechnet?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Da ist auf jeden Fall ganz viel.
Wollen wir nicht selbst über Dinge reden, von denen wir auch Ahnung haben?
Ist eigentlich ganz einfach. 5 Prozent von 20 Milliarden ist 1 Milliarde.
Aber was ich ganz hübsch finde, ist, dass du Pyson startest, um einen Taschenrechner zu haben.
Welcher denn?
Ich wohne bei Pyson Shell.
Ein anderes Thema, das jetzt auch schon...
Ich kann direkt eintippen und wenn ich zahlen öfter brauche, mache ich mir eine Variabel draus und dann kann ich mit der weiter rechnen. Das ist wie Programmieren.
Das ist wie Programmieren, so Pyson.
Ich kann immer nur diesen BC, DC und so.
Wir versuchen mal, uns nicht weiter zu unterbrechen. Max wollte was einbringen.
Wir haben noch ein Thema. Ich frage mich, ob Steve Jobs schon Fehlwales malt.
Wir müssen noch über Mobile Me reden, genau.
Wenn Twitter down ist, dann kommt immer so ein hübsches Bild von so Pögelchen, die probieren, den Wal aus dem Wasser zu heben. Und darum sagt eigentlich jeder, wenn Twitter da ist, oh, wie niedlich. Und das fehlt bei Mobile Me noch ein bisschen, weil Downs sind so oft genug.
Also du meinst, Apple braucht einfach bessere Fehlermeldungen.
Apple braucht bessere Fehlermeldungen. Schickt uns bitte, schickt an steve.sjobs.apple.com. Schönere Fehlermeldungen, damit der Dienst endlich mal populär wird.
Ja, der Fail Whale. Das hast du noch nicht gehört. Das ist schon ein richtiges Internet-Meme geworden.
Ich hab grad gehört, die Vögel, die versuchen, den Wal aus dem Wasser zu schütteln.
Das ist ja so ein schöner Blauwal oder zumindest ein blauer Wal. Und das sieht irgendwie ganz schick aus. Und der Fail Whale wird jetzt sozusagen das Symbol des Scheiterns gepaart mit guter Laune.
Okay, also ich sehe grad hier der letzte Mobile-Me-Update, weil die haben mir jetzt einen Blog eingeführt, nachdem Steve gesagt hat, den müsst ihr jetzt mal ein bisschen bloggen, was er da verkackt.
Ohne Erster Speed allerdings.
Ja, und der hat irgendwie dreimal gebloggt, das letzte Mal, am 29. Juli, und da meinten sie wohl, dass jetzt erstmal alles wieder läuft, auch für die restlichen 1% und so. Also richtig doll vieles ist nicht, aber vielleicht läuft es ja auch jetzt.
Aber es war doch nie mehr als 1%, was Probleme hatte, oder?
Na, man kann sich das so vorstellen, dass sie wahrscheinlich für Mobile Me haben die 100 Server, wo sie ihre User drauf verteilen, weil es kann ja nicht ein Rechner alleine machen, bei den 100.000 Usern, und einer von den 100 Servern hat halt mal ganz doll groß verkackt, und deswegen war 1% betroffen. So würde ich das mal sehen.
Da hab ich aber andere Sachen gehört. Also ich hab, wo hab ich denn das gelesen? Ich glaube bei AskTechnica, dass die Apple-Netzwerk-Infrastruktur wohl richtig, richtig scheiße sei. Also jedes Team hat seine eigenen Server rumstehen, und die dann irgendwie, und guckt mal hier und so. Und das wesentliche Infrastruktur-Teile bei Apple wohl über einen Server laufen, und dafür gibt's dann noch mal irgendwo einen Backup-Server, und das Ganze überhaupt nicht skalieren kann.
Das glaubst du ja selber nicht, oder?
Das Web-Server und App-Server teilweise eine dieselbe Maschine sind damit, sodass das überhaupt nicht skalieren kann.
Das geht bei der Firma nicht mehr mit einem einzigen Rechner.
Also ich meine, zu behaupten, dass Apple keine Ahnung von Online-Diensten hat, ist etwas vermessen. Weil iTunes ist ein Online-Dienst und der hat einfach...
iTunes kriegen sie auf die Reihe. Das stimmt.
Ja, das macht nicht ein Server, das kriegst du einfach nicht mehr hin.
Und ich meine, so Download und Distributionen und auch so interaktive Bedienung, das haben sie an sich schon raus.
Und die haben sich ja bei Akamai eingekauft damals. Also die machen ja ganz, ganz viel mit Akamai zusammen.
Ja, aber mit Akamai allein ist halt so ein Dienst nicht erschlagen. Ich meine, iTunes-Downloads, das ist halt etwas, da musst du nur Files, die sich nicht ändern, replizieren. Und so ein Syncing ist einfach eine ganz andere Anforderung. Ich glaube, das ist das, was ihnen Schwierigkeiten gemacht hat.
Wie Files, die sich nicht ändern?
Na so ein Download von iTunes, diese Files, die ändern sich nicht. Die sind immer dieselben.
Da steht doch dein Name drin.
Das macht aber das iTunes-Lokal.
Erst, wenn es angekommen ist?
Ganz sicher, das hat irgendjemand mal rausgefunden. Also das DRM wird tatsächlich erst auf deinem Rechner hinzugefügt. Theoretisch ist das auch nochmal so ein Angriffsvektor. Aber das, was übertragen wird, das ist ungeschützt. Und der Schutz findet sozusagen erst in der Delivery statt. Das ist eigentlich eine konzeptionelle Sicherheitslücke.
Aber es ist auch ganz gut, sonst hätten wir ja ordentlich viel Arbeit und die Dateien wären eben nicht mehr statisch, sondern dynamisch und wir müssten jedes Mal viel rechnen und das ist halt schwierig.
Genau. Und so können sie das halt schön replizieren. Also das funktioniert ja wunderbar. Ich meine, auch mit Streaming haben sie Erfahrung. Das kriegen sie alles hin. Aber, und ich meine auch, gut mit DotMac haben sie natürlich jetzt auch schon so einige Erfahrungen gehabt. Aber die Reaktion auf das Desaster, eine davon ist ja, dass sie jetzt eine Reorganisation gemacht haben und das erste Mal überhaupt diesen Online-Service, MobileMe, demselben Chef unterstellt haben, wie eben auch iTunes. Das heißt, was mich ein bisschen wundert, weil ja iTunes nun auch so eine Rolle gespielt hat, schon immer mit dem Syncing. Und manches, was vorher mit iTunes gesyncht wurde, wird jetzt nicht mehr mit iTunes gesyncht. Und das ist ja auch alles total durcheinander jetzt. Also ich blicke mittlerweile nicht mehr durch. Und das finde ich, ist ein echtes Warnsignal. Nicht, weil es jetzt generell ein Signal ist, wenn ich nicht mehr durchblicke.
Dann wäre eigentlich...
Aber ich finde mich derzeit nicht in der Lage, überhaupt zu erklären, was da jetzt überhaupt mit was synkt. Wo stellt man überhaupt was wie ein, was mit wem synkt und mit welchem Protokoll wird gesynkt? Ich blicke nicht mehr. Das ist alles total durcheinander. Fängt mit diesen Kalendergeschichten an, da weiß man schon gar nicht mehr, wie, also überhaupt über welche Protokolle wird denn da überhaupt gesynkt. Also was sprechen diese Tools für eine Sprache miteinander? Man möchte ja meinen, dass es dieser Kaldorf-Standard ist, um diese Kalender zu synken. Aber so wie das eigentlich Kaldorf sich gedacht hat, scheint es ja auch nicht zu sein. Und was kommt jetzt? Jetzt kommt Google mit seinem Kalenderservice und hat ein Update und bietet jetzt auf einmal Kaldorf-Syncing. Das heißt, Google macht das kostenlos, was Apple noch nicht mal gegen Geld hinkriegt.
Aber dafür geht es auf dem iPhone nicht.
Ja, und es geht auch auf dem iPhone nicht, weil der Kalender zumindest auch keinen Kaldorf macht. Also das ist irgendwie alles unklar und ich sehe da die klare Linie nicht mehr. Und es hat so viele Nebeneffekte. Du kannst Sachen nicht synchronisieren, wenn du deinen Syncing mit Mobile Me einstellst, dann verlierst du halt Fähigkeiten, andere Kalender zu synchronisieren. Du kannst auch nur alle Kalender auf einmal synchronisieren und einmal sinken und kannst nicht selektieren, wie das vorher mit.Mac noch möglich war. Das sind einfach so Sachen, die verstehe ich.
Aber Mobile Me kriegt jetzt auch einen neuen Chef?
Das ist halt was ich meinte. Sie sind jetzt dem iTunes-Chef unterstellt.
Genau, der diesen App Store so wunderbar auf die Reihe gekriegt hat, an dem wir alle überhaupt nichts auszusetzen haben. Ja...
Die Download-Zahlen werden im App Store immer noch nicht gezeigt, ne?
Aber es gibt jetzt die ersten Heimatstatistik.
Doch, die Download-Zahlen werden jetzt gezeigt.
Wo willst denn du das jetzt? Du hast gar kein iPhone.
Ich habe so... Ich habe was Zwitschern hören.
Ich guck mal hier.
Es ist ja auch im Internet berichtet worden, dass halt Developer jetzt Zugang haben auf tägliche Verkaufsstatistik.
Null Downloads.
Nur rückwirkend. Also nicht rückwirkend, sondern nur die letzten Tage, abdem sie es eingeschaltet haben. Kann sein, dass sie mittlerweile auch die alten Zahlen nachgetragen haben. Das weiß ich nicht. Last time I checked, war es halt so. Immerhin können sie jetzt halbwegs mal sehen, wie ihre Programme ankommen.
Aber so Updates kommen jetzt von den Programmen so langsam durch. Eben zum Beispiel gibt es 1.2. Ein anderes Programm hatte das auch, ein Update erschienen.
Stehen jetzt noch die richtigen Updates-Versionsnummern da?
Ja, die Versionsnummern stehen auch da, aber es steht trotzdem da Null Downloads.
Hast du ein NetNews-Wire runtergeladen? Kannst du das mal machen bitte? Gucken wir mal, welche Version das ist.
Wir werden übrigens gerade, ich finde das mit dem Livestream ganz großartig, weil Sven chattet mich gerade an, wir sitzen in LA, nicht in Leipzig, sondern in Los Angeles, und hört uns gerade zu, wir werden weltweit gehört, sozusagen.
Das ist wahr.
Also NetNews-Wire ist die Version 1.0.1 vom 25. Juli, Null Downloads bisher, ich mach jetzt mal einen Download.
Das ist nicht die 1.0.1, das ist die 1.0.7. Ja genau, lad das mal runter, das hat sonst niemand.
Oh Gott, alles eingeben.
Auf meinen Soße ist es auch drauf.
Wir müssen jetzt weiter quatschen.
Ich hab grad mal Twitter gelesen, also hier kommt ja wirklich, also Twitter ist, ich find Twitter immer noch toll. Das ist das, was mich wirklich überrascht.
Weil sie einen Failwale haben. Mobile maybe auch toll, wenn wir einen Failwale hätten.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Wir sollten eine Petition daraus machen.
Was ich am meisten mag an Twitter, das wird mir jetzt gerade klar.
Was denn?
Ich mag die Leute, die auf Twitter sind.
Total, oder?
Also die sind einfach offen, und die sind kommunikationsfreudig und experimentierfreudig, und da kriegt man einfach Antworten.
Und jeder, der nervt, dem anfolgt man einfach.
Ja, man kann das ganz gut filtern, und das ist einfach irgendwie ein geiler Chat. Und alle Leute, die einfach gerne und offen kommunizieren, die tun das, und das ist extrem kollaborativ. Also man wird hier nicht angepflaumt, zumindest in der Regel nicht, und das ist irgendwie so eine schöne virtuelle Realität in gewisser Hinsicht. Und vor allem ist das ganz praktisch. Also die Leute, die jetzt hier zuhören, die kommentieren hier auch ganz fleißig. Das lenkt einen natürlich so ein bisschen ab, aber dafür sind wir ja auch drei. Da kann immer einer ein bisschen...
Was soll ich jetzt machen mit dem NetNews-Wire?
Und Dennis? 101 wird da angezeigt, immer noch nicht falsch. Immer noch?
Das ist doch wirklich unglaublich. Dieser Upstore ist wirklich eine Katastrophe. Diese Statistik sah auch sehr aus, also diese Download-Statistik für die Applikation, die hatte so viele Spalten, die sich irgendwie so auf, wo so Artist und so was war. Also man merkte richtig, dass es dieselbe Software ist, die auch die Statistik für die Musik für die entsprechenden Anbieter darstellt.
Aber ist trotzdem der beste Mobile-Job, den es gibt, oder?
Keine Frage. Und ich meine, sie haben auf jeden Fall auch eine Menge, weiß ich, wie viele Applikationen es gibt. Ich hab mal diesen RSS-Feed abonniert, wo neue Programme vorgestellt werden. Es rauscht jeden Tag, kommen da 50 neue Apps.
Das sind schon viele, wobei...
Also das wird nicht mehr lange dauern und die haben da 5000.
Hat irgendjemand diese wunderbaren Calvin & Jobs Comics gesehen, die jetzt gerade so rumgehen? Das heißt so ein Calvin & Hope-Stil? Ich hab nur davon gehört, dass Hobbs durch Steve Jobs ersetzt wurde und natürlich genau die gleiche Puppe ist.
Calvin & Jobs, Kicks, Giftwitters.
Das ist ziemlich witzig. Das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, das zu lesen. Dein halber Bildschirm besteht aus Tabs. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich nicht mit so einem kleinen Monitor klarkomme.
Und du brauchst doch wirklich alle da?
Ich arbeite der Reihe nach ab.
Wenn du so viele Tabs hast, solltest du Omni-Web benutzen.
Wieso?
Weil das da einfach mal vertikal ist mit Preview-Icons. Oder NetNews-File.
Guck mal, ich kann hier eigentlich so ein Button, da drücke ich drauf, dann muss da mir... Dann macht die doch dann da oben weg. Ich finde die da oben super.
Jetzt können unsere Zuhörer gar nicht sehen, was wir jetzt machen.
Kann man die auch resizing?
Ich weiß nicht.
Die hat dir eben da angezeigt, dass hier das Thumbnail ist. Max zeigt uns nämlich gerade ein Firefox-Feature, was echt cool ist. Man kann die Tabs auch als Thumbnails machen. Wenn du es jetzt kleiner machst, wird es auch... Kleiner. Ja, nicht schnell, aber es funktioniert. Das ist cool.
Tim hat etwas halb Positives über Firefox gesagt.
Ja, ich hab ja gar nichts dagegen. Ich gehöre es bloß nicht benutzen. Ich nerf das.
Wovon sind wir jetzt gerade abgekommen?
Sind diese Calvin & Jobs-Dinger irgendwie wienenswert?
Ja, wir machen einen Link.
Ja, ich finde die ganz großartig.
Twitter doch nochmal so einen Link, damit ich mir das auch mal angucken kann. Aber einen, der wirklich witzig ist und nicht so einer, der auf der halben Strecke stecken bleibt. Noch mal kurz hier zum Mobile-Mess. Ich würde jetzt liebend gerne mal die Details zusammenfassen, aber ich habe leider keine Zeit gehabt, das wirklich zu recherchieren. Aber es ist einfach kaputt. Es ist einfach featuremäßig so kaputt. Wenn man nämlich Mobile-Media verwendet, dann nimmt es einem einfach die Flexibilität. Ich habe ja dieses Problem unter anderem, ich möchte gerne einen Kalender mit mehreren Leuten teilen, der hilft mir einfach Mobile-Media kein Stück weiter. Ich kann das zwar zwischen meinen Devices hin und her singen, und dann habe ich da irgendwie dasselbe, aber diesen eigentlichen Effekt, den ich haben will, nämlich ich mache mir hier einen Kalender und gebe diesen Kalender frei, damit auch andere Leute, die jetzt nicht meinen Mobile-Media-Account benutzen, verwenden können. Diese Funktionalität gibt es immer noch nicht. Und jetzt kommt halt Google-Kalender, die vor einer Woche das angekündigt haben, dass sie das jetzt unterstützen. Ist natürlich mal wieder alles Beta und es gibt auch noch eine Menge Einschränkungen. Aber man kann sich jetzt in iCal so einen CalDAF-Account machen. Da trägt man dann seinen Google-Account quasi ein und die URL von diesem Kalender, mit der Google selber halt im Webinterface meint, dass das die URL für diesen Kalender sei. Und dann kann man den halt abonnieren. Und man kann den ja auch sharen innerhalb des Webinterfaces und sagen hier, jemand anderes soll da eben auch mitarbeiten.
Das geht ziemlich großartig.
Da hat man einen richtigen kollaborativen Kalender und man hat das trotzdem im iCal.
Das heißt, du könntest jetzt für unsere Sendung hier irgendwie dir so ein Google-Dings-Kalender holen. Ich könnte den abonnieren und dann kannst du mir dann meine Termine reinrücken.
Wir könnten sowas zum Beispiel mal auch gleich mal aufsetzen. Das ist eine gute Idee für Mobile Max. Tatsächlich hab ich das schon angefangen.
Und wir hören auch, dann wissen sie auch gleich, wann sie beim nächsten Livestream reinhören können.
Da gibt es ja noch so Chats.
Das stimmt. Man könnte den sogar so richtig public machen.
Und das geht alles mit Mobile Mi nicht.
Das wäre mir neu.
Ich meine, Mobile Mi ist doch eigentlich eh für einen Arsch. Wir reden davon, dass wir unsere Daten irgendwie nicht in die USA, Israel und andere Staaten einführen wollen, weil die da meinen, sie dürfen da drauf gucken, machen und tun. Nicht, dass sie Terrorist sind, aber privat ist das privat. Das geht denen scheiß an. Und gleichzeitig schicke ich Sachen irgendwie von meine Kalender, meine E-Mails, mein Zeug mit zur Mobile-Mio. Das kann ich noch nicht so richtig verstehen.
Ich mach das nicht, also ich nutze das dafür nicht.
Naja, aber tausende andere und ich kann es nicht so richtig nachvollziehen. Also ich könnte es nachvollziehen, wenn mein Rechner, die vorher verschlüsselt, das Verschlüsselte dorthin schickt, das Verschlüsselte von dort wiederholt und die sozusagen immer nur das Verschlüsselte da haben. Dann würde ich das ja kapieren, aber so...
Ich kann dir haargenau sagen, warum die Leute das machen, der gleiche Grund, warum ich es auch mache, ist es ungeheuer bequem.
Sicherlich.
Ne, aber so bequem ist es auch nicht.
Doch, doch.
Und da ist Apple nämlich evil, weil nämlich, dass jeder sich seinen eigenen oder nicht jeder, aber so eine Firma, zum Beispiel, sich einen Mac OS X Server hinstellt und sich nicht Mobile Mii benutzt, sondern den Mac OS X Server, der genau die gleichen Features nutzt, können sie dann über den OS X Server-Preis irgendwie das Geld wieder reinholen. Das wäre irgendwie toll, wenn man das pro Firma wenigstens so was machen könnte, dann muss man halt seiner Firma vertrauen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall schonmal nicht gleich, dass Apple irgendwie alle 100.000 User immer erwachen könnte, sondern da geht es ein bisschen kleiner, so wie Exchange das halt macht. Und dann, das würde ich besser finden, aber das machen die natürlich nicht, weil da verdienen die halt nicht genug dran.
Aber ein Exchange-Server könntest du ja mittlerweile aufsetzen einfach.
Ja, Exchange will ich ja nicht, ich will ja schon was irgendwie...
Das haarige ist, meine, Kaldav, darauf basieren ja auch Mac OS X Server. Also sie haben ja einen Kaldav-Server. Und sogar, wenn du von Apple für teuer Geld, für 1000 Dollar, dir so einen Server kaufst, kannst du es nicht benutzen mit deinem iPhone.
Das ist total albern.
Also mit deinem iCard kannst du es natürlich schon benutzen, aber du kannst es halt nicht dann sünden und so weiter.
Und man kann zwar...
Das muss aber noch kommen. Also das kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass sie dieses Feature aus dem iPhone rauslassen.
Also wahrscheinlich hat irgendjemand gesagt, ok, Enterprise ist jetzt die nächste Generation und Enterprise muss Exchange sein. Und daraufhin wurde da einfach der gesamte Schwerpunkt gelegt.
Enterprise ist die nächste Generation?
Vom iPhone. iPhone 2.0 Richtung Enterprise. War damals wahrscheinlich direkt die Ansage.
Voll die Star Trek Analogien hier irgendwie. Erst war es Enterprise und dann ist es irgendwie Next Generation.
Ich denke, bei Enterprise denke ich mittlerweile, ich bin so verkommen, ich denke mittlerweile wirklich an Leute.
Nur noch an Geld.
An Leute in Anzüge.
Wirklich?
Ja, ich möchte schon.
Ich habe mir meine jugendliche Romantik noch erhalten. Ich denke einfach an Raumschiffe, wenn du sagst Enterprise.
Sehr schön. Ich probiere da auch wieder hinzu. Ich mache mal die Augen zu und denke an.
Ja, und dann kommt Apple und kündigt Enterprise fürs iPhone an und du kannst das Ding immer noch nicht benutzen.
Und ich habe immer noch Frontiers.
Wie heißen denn noch gleich diese Devices in Star Trek?
Kommunikator.
Nein, nein.
Börsenkurse. Nein.
Doch, das ist der... Ach so, das ist der Handhalt oder was wir an der Post haben? Der Trikorder.
Genau, gibt es eine Trikorder-Anwendung? Gibt es schon einen Trikorder?
Das ist gerade die Marktlücke entdeckt.
Ja, jetzt kann man...
Was macht der so...
Genau.
Okay, ist genug Luft hier.
Ja, du kannst genau...
Ihr wisst ja, dass der... Der Scotty, den wollten sie gerade mit der Rakete hochschießen, mit der Falcon 3 oder was auch immer.
Ach, der gestorben ist.
Ja, und die Rakete ist doch geplatzt oder so. Das heißt, Scotty ist jetzt doch nicht im Weltraum. Der ist jetzt verloren gegangen.
In der Atmosphäre verglüht oder was?
Ja, wieder runtergekommen. Den ist die Rakete beim Start explodiert und irgendwo...
Mit Scotty.
Mit Scotty und diversen anderen Toten.
Es war wohl geplant, dass er im Weltraum irgendwie und so weiter. Das hat dann nicht funktioniert.
Ich hoffe...
War nichts mit beam me up Scotty.
Es gibt keinen Trikorder.
Es gibt keine Trikorder-Applikation?
Nein. Also findet der Store keinen... Vielleicht gibt es einen und er findet sie nicht.
Ich glaube, in dieser Sekunde wären acht Export-Projekte gestartet, die alle Trikorder heißen.
Ich bin schon fertig.
Mich wundert das sehr. Weil soweit ich mich erinnern kann, waren das so für andere mobile Devices, so wie für ein Palm oder so. Da gab es das relativ...
Ja, aber Star Trek ist jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen vorbei.
Die sind alle noch dabei, ihre Flashlight-Versionen.
Nee, die haben sie wahrscheinlich alle einfach noch nicht durchgelassen bei Apple, weil irgendwie wahrscheinlich wegen Urheberrechtsverfahren... Wahrscheinlich hat Apple einen Deal mit... Star Trek in Amerika gemacht, NBC. Und darum, um sich den Deal nicht zu versauen, lassen sie jetzt keine Trikorder-Applikation bis die offizielle Enterprise... Watsch! Hallo ein bisschen! Also ich meine, wir können uns ja auch ausdenken jetzt hier schön. Und dass darum einfach noch nicht reingelassen wird. Also anders ist es wirklich nicht erklärbar.
Das stimmt.
Oder hat sich wirklich noch niemand...
Wir fordern auf jeden Fall die Developer-Community, die uns wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht zuhört, aber wir fordern sie trotzdem auch...
Da hätte man jetzt filmen müssen, wie Tim sich hinstellt, wie der Papst und...
Hier wurde auch schon nach dem Live-Video-Stream gefragt.
Was machen wir dann beim nächsten Mal?
Das kostet aber Geld dann.
Echt? So Talking-Hats, ich finde das langweilig.
Aber nur wenn du dich... dann ziehst du dich auch aus, oder? Schon wieder?
Das können die gar nicht bezahlen.
Haben wir jetzt genug auf MobileMe rumgeratet. Ich kann leider substanziell nicht viel sagen. Ich wollte irgendwie noch erklären, wie das alles nicht funktioniert, aber irgendwie finde ich es auch langweilig.
Aber es scheint unsere Hörer auch gar nicht so zu interessieren, weil da gibt es ja kaum Fragen im Forum, oder? Zum MobileMe?
Ach so, du meinst den Kommentaren. Ich wurde schon gefragt, wann wir denn anfangen, auf MobileMe einzuschlagen. Und in dem Moment haben wir es dann auch getan.
Ja, aber ich finde jetzt nicht, dass da Leute so viele Fragen stellen und sagen, wieso funktioniert das oder sonst nichts.
Dennis, könntest du dir bitte einen Twitter-Account machen?
Oh man, ey!
Könntest du mal Dennis2.0 sein?
Dennis2.0? Okay, was muss ich denn machen nach der Sendung?
Ja, es geht ganz schnell.
Was muss ich runterladen?
Ja und follow mich, ich hänge hier eh nicht gerade an. Das ist ganz furchtbar, ich hänge hier seit...
Aber da gibt es auch Clients, habt ihr gesagt.
Da gibt es Clients, du kannst ja auch Twitterifik installieren, wenn du das irgendwie so hübsch in Pop-up und mit Zwitscher-Zwitscher-Sound haben möchtest.
Ich hänge hier seit... Jetzt ist der auch noch dabei.
Dennis macht sich mal einen Account, dann kann ich ja nochmal kurz erklären, wie das mit dem Google-Kalender funktioniert und was das Problem ist. Weil eins geht nämlich noch nicht so, wie man sich das vorstellt. Man würde ja meinen, dass man da einmal seinen Account einträgt und dann sieht man alle seine Kalender, die man da hat. So geht das aber nicht. Sondern man muss für jeden einzelnen Kalender, den man da hat, einen eigenen Account machen. Das sieht natürlich dann im Ende so ein bisschen blöd aus. In iCal. In iCal gehst du in die Präferenzes und dann machst du dir einen...
Für dieses Google-Web-Call, denkst du?
Genau, oder für jeden anderen Call-Docs, den du selber hast. Da gehst du halt in Accounts und sagst halt irgendwie plus und dann gibst du dem einen Namen, das ein bisschen doppel gemobbelt ist, weil du nämlich sowohl einen Namen für diesen Account hast, als dann auch nochmal den Namen des Kalenders auch noch siehst. Und es gibt da so recht keinen Grund, das zu unterscheiden, weil eigentlich will man ja mehrere Kalender unter diesem einen Account sehen, aber das funktioniert ebenso nicht. Und weil das Google irgendwie noch nicht so unterstützt im Protokoll. Wir haben zwar CalDAF, aber eben noch nicht so richtig...
Das ist das Google-Problem sozusagen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, CalDAF kann doch noch was werden. Die sind da einfach noch am Anfang. Aber hast du zwei Kalender, brauchst eben zwei solche Einträge dafür. Und du musst dir dann halt eben in diesen Sharing-Settings in Google-Kalender die URL dafür anschauen. Was, dann bist du bei Twitter oder was?
El Mudo würde ich sagen. Das andere ist...
Ich erkläre das nochmal kurz zu Ende. Man muss sich diese URL zusammenbauen mit dieser Kalender-ID, die da angezeigt wird. Kalender-ID ist dann eben für den Standard. Default-Kalender ist das so dein username at Gmail, und das Ganze ist dann eben eingebettet in https www.google.com/kalender/dav und dann eben deine E-Mail-Adresse und dann slash user und dann hast du deinen Default-Kalender und für jeden anderen Kalender genau das Gleiche. Bloß dann musst du eben diese Kalender-ID, die dir an einer Stelle angezeigt wird. Das ist dann irgendwie sowas wie mc8dn34 tra la la kryptisches Zeichen at group.kalender.google.com und dann wieder slash user und dann hat man das eben.
Ich bin nach wie vor glücklicher User von BusySync.
Ah ja, davon habe ich auch schon mehrere Sachen gehört.
Das kostet leider relativ viel mit 25 Dollar. Ist auch nicht absolut perfekt. Also was mich zum Beispiel nervt, dass ich irgendwann mal ziemlich große Logfiles von BusySync entdeckt habe, die es nicht löscht nach einer Zeit. Aber ansonsten funktioniert das, nachdem man es einmal eingerichtet hat, relativ unauffällig im Hintergrund. Es wird alles synchronisiert und hat ein paar Features, die die DAFK-Lösung noch nicht hat.
Muss man hier den Dennis Darth Vader-Funktionen ein bisschen minimieren.
Ich reg mich so auf wegen diesem scheiß Twitter-Zeug.
Ach komm. Wie heißt denn? Dennis2342. Ich follow dich mal.
Echt? Dennis ist auf Twitter.
Dennis ist auf Twitter.
Nee, ich find's immer bekloppt, wenn die immer Passwörter haben wollen, dann sagen sie nicht, wofür die genau da sind und so weiter. Dann kloppt man alle drin und sagt, jetzt wollen sie schon das nächste haben.
Du hast die Hauptfunktion von Twitter entdeckt, auf Twitter rumhacken. Sehr gut.
Man kann jetzt mitmachen beim Twitter-Ranting.
So, wir müssen jetzt noch, während des Podcasts müssen wir hier noch Dennis auf mindestens, sagen wir mal, 50 Follower kriegen. 50 kriegen wir hin.
Haben wir denn so viele Zuhörer überhaupt?
Ich hätte das gerne nicht im Browser, sondern als extra Programm.
Dann ladet ihr Twitter-Refik runter.
46 Hörer und wir beide sind 48. Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt noch 2 Hörer generieren.
Warte mal, wir machen jetzt, wir erpressen jetzt wieder. Und wo gibt es Twitter-Refik? Bei iconfactory.com.
Aber da war ich da schon, ich wollte mir nur fürs iPhone Zeug anbieten. Ich will ja aber nicht auf meinem Rechner haben.
Da, lad's dir runter.
Da, iPhone Touch, Zeugs, Download.
Dann klick hier auf Get it.
Ach dit, wer soll denn das sehen?
Wer soll denn diesen Download-Link entdecken?
Echt mal.
Okay, also.
Haben wir denn noch mal so richtige News, sag mal, bevor wir so...
Max, wir haben dich unterbrochen. Als du gerade schön erklären wolltest, BusySync vor dem Nachteil.
BusySync wirkt nicht ganz hundertprozentig perfekt, ist aber ganz hübsch. Und was der Vorteil ist, man kann nämlich bei Einträgen, die man im iCall hat, und wenn man die dann mit seinem iPhone synchronisiert, kann man auf dem iPhone trotzdem nicht noch Kalendereinträge aktualisieren. Was nicht geht, wenn du irgendeinen blöden DuffCall-Kalender abonniert hast, weil die kann man dann einfach zwar auf dem iPhone sich angucken, schön, aber nicht mehr bearbeiten.
Geht die überhaupt aufs iPhone? Die per CalDuff abonnierten?
Ich glaube, die kann man synchronisieren, aber ebenso wie RSS-Kalender nur zum Angucken. Aber ich hab's noch nicht probiert. Das ist bei BusySync überhaupt kein Problem. Das nutzt diese Google-AP im Hintergrund und schiebt die iCall unten drunter.
Achso, das basiert sozusagen auf Google-Kalender?
Genau, das basiert auf Google-Kalender. BusySync ist eine Software, die dafür da ist, um mein iCall-Kalender mit meinem Google-Kalender zu synchronisieren.
Aha, nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Nicht mehr und nicht weniger. Und dadurch kann man mit anderen Leuten relativ einfach einen Kalender teilen, zum Beispiel in einer Büroumgebung oder so was. Und man trägt dann seine Termine ganz normal an iCall ein und die anderen kriegen die.
Das heißt, das kann man auch jetzt parallel zu dieser anderen Geschichte machen?
Das sollte eigentlich parallel zu der anderen Geschichte relativ gut laufen, ja.
So, aha, das fragt mich jetzt nach einer Mailing-Liste. Ah, Trial Mode, 30 Tage, okay. Das werd ich mal ausprobieren, das ist eine gute Idee. Schick, ja mir ist das auch schon mehrfach empfohlen worden, aber ich hatte bisher noch keine Zeit, das irgendwie zu machen. So, dann kann ich jetzt jeden Kalender sozusagen, auch explizit, achso, der publiziert mir das dann auch automatisch auf meinen Google-Kalender-Account, oder was? Der publiziert mir das dann sozusagen auch gleich. Kann ich lokal einen Kalender machen und dann...
Du kannst auch sagen, ja, pack dir nach oben oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie genau das ging. Also die Einstellung ist ein bisschen kompliziert.
Ja, das stimmt, ist ein bisschen verwirrend. Na gut, das werd ich mir mal in Ruhe anschauen und dann können wir das nächste Mal drüber reden. Nicht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwie im Wald rumstochern. Was gibt's noch?
Und dann ist es bei Twitterrific. Und jetzt nun? Jetzt musst du Leute followen. Jetzt geh mal auf die Seite.
Du musst nur Leuten followen, wenn du denen zuhören willst.
Zum Beispiel mir. Tim, kannst du jetzt Proforma followen? Das geht über die Webseite.
Wird nicht da?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber die tauchen ja bei Twitterifik gar nicht auf. Also du siehst ja da sozusagen nur die Leuten, denen du folgst. Das heißt, du gehst jetzt auf meine Homepage auf Twitter. Also twitter.com/timbritlove. Da ist ein großer Button, da steht drauf follow. So, und das ist im Prinzip so ein inklusiver Chat. Das heißt, wenn du jemanden folgst, dann ist das halt noch jemand, der in deinem deiner Chat-Sicht auf Twitter sozusagen auftaucht. Und du heißt? 343max. 343max und timbritlove, das sind die...
So, und du hast schon 13 Follower.
Wo kommen die denn alle her?
Das frage ich mich auch, wo die alle herkommen. Du hast noch ganz viele, ne?
Max, ich hatte vorhin, das war ganz furchtbar... Ah, und da ist die Mail, dass du mir jetzt followst. Ich hatte die ganze Zeit über 666 Follower.
Und du fandest das total super.
Nee, ich fand das total scheiße, vor allem weil Nummer 666 war ausgerechnet noch ein Anwalt.
Filipp Riederler, Follower 10. Wieso krieg ich das jetzt hier?
Jetzt bin ich aber deutlich drüber.
Boah, weißt du, dass es ein Anwalt war?
Weil Anwälte sich RA irgendwas nennen und weil er den Namen Markenrecht hat. twitter.com/markenrecht.
Wenn ich dem gar nicht follow, warum kriege ich das dann?
Das ist, wenn jemand dir direkte Nachricht schickt, mit diesem Add-Zeichen vorne dran, also Add, Dennis, irgendwas. Genau, das geht dann an dich, dann kriegst du das.
Das ist nicht die direkte Nachricht, sondern das ist explizit ein sogenannter Reply. Eine direkte Nachricht ist, wenn du D, Name, Nachricht sagst, dann ist das so eine richtige private Message.
Und wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel, genau, mach mal hier D, Leerzeichen 343 Max.
Ob das jetzt wirklich spannend ist für Leute, uns dabei zuzuhören, wie wir irgendwie Dennis Twitter-Account machen? Ich frag mich wirklich, wie das ist. Können vielleicht mal die Leute auf Twitter sagen, ob das überhaupt spannend ist. Ist wahrscheinlich spannend, wenn man live zuhört und die Leute, die das jetzt im Podcast hören, sind völlig genervt und denken sich, jetzt krieg ich von dir auf Sandy die Nachricht. Jetzt investier ich hier so viel Zeit und an sowas.
Haben wir denn noch schicke Themen?
Also, ich hab nur noch die Information, dass Firewire immer noch nicht tot ist und fleißig daran weiter gearbeitet wird. Und sie träumen von Firewire 3200.
Na, es wurde ja auch verabschiedet darauf. Heiße vor ein paar Tagen schon. Das sind die gleichen Stecker, es ist auch abwärtskompatibel. Es sind dann 3,2 Gigabit, also ganz leicht schneller als SATA 2. Aber es hat ja mit Apple eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu tun, weil sie haben es ja abgegeben. Deswegen ist es ja auch ein IEEE-Standard, richtig? Und das ist halt die Frage, ob Apple das dann selbst einsetzen wird.
Das ist die Frage. Ist die Frage, ob sie überhaupt noch auf Firewire setzen für die Zukunft. Oder ob sie nicht mit Intel, was ja so meine Vermutung ist, da schon so einen Geheimbund aufgesetzt haben und den USB 3.0 alles reinbauen, was Apple schon immer haben wollte.
Also irgendwie ist so ein bisschen...
Unklar...
.Firewire wird immer stiefmütterlicher behandelt, oder?
Na ja, am Rechner war ja erst die erste Intel-Generation, hatte ja kein Firewire 800, weil das Intel-Chip-Set kein Firewire 800 konnte, angeblich. Danach haben sie es dann doch wieder eingeführt. Dann hätten sie es ja auch dann schon weglassen können, wenn sie gerade schon so halb dabei waren.
Derzeit können sie es nicht... Also in den Pro-Modellen können sie es nicht weglassen. Es gibt einfach zu viel Equipment, was wirklich Firewire 800 auch benötigt.
Und die ganzen HD-Kameras und so, Final Cut, das ist doch auch alles Firewire. Wenn denen mit USB 2.0 kommt, sie lachen nicht aus.
Ja, wobei gerade im Kamerabereich geht es weg von Firewire. Es geht jetzt einfach hin zu festplattenbasierten Kameras. Die bauen jetzt alle Flash oder richtig gleich Hardtests mit den Kameras rein und dann mountest du das halt einfach über USB. Das ist viel einfacher, weil dann brauchst du dieses ganze Reinladen nicht mehr. Das nervt ja, weil das auch nur in Realtime geht. Und wenn du da drei Stunden Footage hast, dann dauert es einfach drei Stunden. Wenn du aber eine Kamera oder Flash da drin hast, also bei Flash ist es sogar noch einfacher, also die neuen Sony-Kameras, die HD... Die haben halt einfach so einen Flash-Chip da drin. Nimmst du raus, irgendwie kannst du einen anderen Reh da reinstecken. Genau und ich denke, das ist auch die Zukunft und das macht auch einfach total Sinn, dass du das einfach als Dateien von Anfang an begreifst und dieses blöde, synchrone Reingestream in den Rechner, was auch total fehleranfällig ist. Was, da passiert dann mal kurz was und dann musst du wieder komplett von vorne anfangen und dann muss man da rumspulen und so. Wobei es auch beim Kopieren auch.
Naja, wenn mitten drin im Datein kopieren, was schief geht, musst du genauso gut.
Ja gut, aber du hast Random Access, so dann kannst du halt da nochmal den Retry machen und den hast du halt dann irgendwie nicht.
So.
Also das ist... Ich denke, es geht einfach weg davon. Es geht hin zu Platten und so weiter. Firewire wird zumindest im Kamerabereich auf langem Frist nicht mehr so wichtig sein.
In welchen Bereichen haben sie denn die Überlebenschance?
Naja, derzeit ist halt Firewire 800 nach wie vor die schnellste Möglichkeit, eine externe Festplatte anzuschließen. Dieses Drobo, worüber wir zum Beispiel schonmal geredet haben. Diese Box, die übrigens nicht AFP macht, wie ich fälschlicherweise behauptet habe, sondern nur SMB, also als Drobo Share. Drobo ist ja, also Provo, du weißt wovon ich redete. Dieses Festplattenteil, wo du einfach Platten reinschiebst und dann ist das immer so ein Rate automatisch.
Genau, das klingt nach einem ziemlich guten Konzept. Also mit Analog...
Denke ich auch. Und das gibt es halt jetzt auch in einer Firewire 800-Version.
Aber man kann da über Netzwerk kein Time Machine Backup drauf machen. Denn es ist nur SMB kann, außer man hackte sich zurecht. Offensichtlich.
Das ist meine Vermutung, ja.
Schade, schade, schade.
Bin mir da nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, weil ich das noch überhaupt nicht ausprobiert habe, aber ich hab danach mal gesucht und irgendwie...
Gibt es auch noch nicht so lange, dass das wirklich jemand hätte ausprobieren können, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange es dieses Produkt gibt, aber ein paar Monate gibt es das auf jeden Fall schon. Der Timo von Bits und so hat sich so ein Teil gekauft. Ich denke, der wird demnächst mal darüber berichten. Da bin ich schon ganz gespannt. Ja, ähm, sonst noch Themen? Mal gucken. Ich hab hier immer so eine schöne Liste. Aber gegen Ende wird es natürlich immer ein bisschen dünn. Aber man kann auch so ein bisschen rumrannten. Hier, hier nochmal aus der Apple is Evil Abteilung. Was auch wieder so ein bisschen uncool ist, es gab ja ein iTunes-Update, 7.7.
7.7.1.
7.7.1 meint wegen auch das. Auf jeden Fall gab es so ein Update. Das alte iTunes war nicht mehr da, jetzt gibt es das neue. Und? Was ist passiert?
Scheiße, vorher.
Es bricht die Rückwärtskompatibilität zur iTunes 6. Kannst jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr etwas, was von iTunes 6 geschert ist, mit iTunes 7.7 angucken. Das schreiben sie auch nicht rein in ihre Updates. Da sagen sie nichts zu, das bricht einfach weg. Und alle Leute, die jetzt zu Hause mit iTunes 6 auf irgendeiner Büchse noch gearbeitet haben. Genau.
Und kein dem sicheres Gesicht.
Haben ein dummes Gesicht. Klar, da kann man sagen, ja, update doch. Aber dieser fortlaufende Update-Zwang, der läuft halt irgendwann ins Leere, wenn du eben da Maschinen hast, die eben nicht das Neueste fahren können. Wegen kann nicht Leopard und so weiter. Und dann kann iTunes irgendwann nur noch, bei iTunes noch nicht ganz so weit. Aber man will halt unter Umständen auch einfach mal ganz bewusst eine alte Software benutzen. Und ich finde es einfach extrem unangemessen, dass Apple über geradezu erzwungene Aktualisierung, ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass man immer die Wahl hätte, jetzt auf einer alten Version zu bleiben, weil du eben neue Hardware nur benutzen kannst und so weiter, wenn du die neueste Version hast. So, und dann bricht einfach diese Rückwärtskompatibilität. Ich meine, wenn es dafür einen guten Grund gäbe, dann würde ich sagen, okay, dann nenn den doch bitte mal. Aber erstens, das ohne guten Grund zu machen, weil hier sehe ich jetzt auch mal keinen, weil das einfach nur ein Stück Kot, was da drin bleiben muss, um das eben zu unterstützen, und das haben sie jetzt aktiv rausgeschmissen. Und wenn sie das dann schon machen, dann sollen sie das doch bitte auch mal sagen. Und zwar vorher. Wenn du das installierst, dann kannst du das und das nicht mehr tun. Das tun sie halt auch nicht. Und das geht einfach alles gar nicht. Ich finde das nicht in Ordnung. Und dann...
Also mir wärs jetzt, hättest du es jetzt gar nicht erwähnt, wärs mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht aufgefallen, aber es ist natürlich immer schade, wenn sowas einfach flöten ist.
Ja, das ist auch unfair. Also es ist wirklich unfair, den Kunden gegenüber einfach Features fallen zu lassen, ohne zumindest darüber aufzuklären, warum sie das tun und überhaupt auch nur, dass sie das tun. Ich hab jetzt nur noch zwei Sachen auf meiner Liste. Wie sieht es bei euch aus? Ich hab gar nichts mehr auf der Liste.
Nee, ich hab auch nichts.
Das wäre jetzt sozusagen die Gelegenheit, unser Zuhörerpublikum doch nochmal aufzufordern, jetzt über Twitter live Fragen zu stellen oder sonstige Hinweise, wo wir noch reden sollten. Sonst hören wir nämlich einfach auf.
Ich dachte, du hast noch zwei Sachen.
Wir werden nicht nur in Los Angeles reden.
Ja, die kommen ja jetzt gleich noch, aber wir brauchen ja noch ein bisschen Vorlauf. Aber hier kommt so viel rein. Dennis, ich muss jetzt mal deinen Twitter-Account irgendwie hier auf Twitter bekannt geben.
So, Dennis gibt es... Wie kann man uns auf dem Campingplatz hören?...
Na, wenn sie nur noch Netz hat, muss sie halt Netz haben. Wie soll es sonst gehen?
So.
Ahnte ich jetzt schon. Also wo hat man in der Pampa Netz?
Man kann auf dem iPhone auch keine Livestreams sich so richtig anhören. Das ist auch noch alles ein bisschen blöd.
Es gibt so ein paar... Und dabei die Person angucken, die kein iPhone hat. Es gibt so ein paar schöne... Also doch, man kann auch Livestreamen, ist ja klar. Ich weiß jetzt... Ich hab's noch nicht probiert. Also auf jeden Fall kann man, meines Wissens, Quicktime streamen und es gibt so eine Applikation im App Store...
Quicktime kannst du schon mal nicht. Wenn du da was mit RTSP machst, dann sagt das iPhone das Format kennst nicht.
Okay, dann nicht die Variante, aber es gibt ein paar... Es gibt im App Store Programme, mit denen man sich Radioprogramme runterladen kann, also mit denen man Radio live hören kann.
Hab ich auch gehört.
Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, weil ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht so...
Weil das wär nämlich noch so...
So ein Streaming Radio Fan, aber...
Ich bin Streaming Radio Fan. Ich hör sehr viel...
Ich find ja, dass das alles, was über Streaming kommt, total scheiße ist. Fast so schlimm wie Podcasts.
Nee, für mich ist das sogar tatsächlich... Also ich hab vollkommen aufgehört, eigene Musikbibliotheken zu hören. Also ich find das ja interessant, dass iTunes so viel Musik verkauft und die Leute immer noch so Musik kaufen, sich auf ihre Rechner laden und so. Aber ich höre, wenn überhaupt nur Musik von hier meinen Freunden aus Kalifornien. Na, wie heißen sie denn hier? Soma FM, ganz großes Kino, ist eine Site, die mehrere Live-Radios online hat und die ernähren sich komplett nur von Spenden. Hab ich auch schon mal hingespendet. Und die haben sehr viele schöne, nette Kanäle. Und ja, Klicksuche in iTunes und hier über meine Infrastruktur mit Airport-Expressen hab ich das halt einfach in der ganzen Wohnung. Da kann man mal wirklich entspannt hier alles so in wattige Musik tauchen. Und vor allem muss ich mir keine Gedanken darüber machen, was ich jetzt als nächstes höre. Ja, und natürlich ist es auch schick, einfach so für Radio, was auch sowieso live auf UKW ist. Derzeit, hab ich schon erwähnt, ne? Aber ich mach's noch mal. Mach ich ja ein paar Live-Sendungen auf Funkwelle, FM. Hast du davon schon gehört? Hast du das schon gehört?
Ich hab's noch nicht gehört, ich hab davon schon gehört.
Das ist halt einfach so ein Radioprojekt. Es gibt ja in Berlin kein freies Radio. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, mal freies Radio zu machen, ist diese Veranstaltungsfrequenz zu kriegen. 95, 95.2. Die sitzen jetzt hier in der Schönhauser Allee in Berlin und senden halt über den Kirchturm, kommen auch recht weit und haben halt so diesen ganzen Gemma-Klimbimm dafür geregelt. Das heißt, da kann man einfach hingehen und senden, was man will. Und die sind, naja, die sind halt so ein bisschen, das ist halt alles, das ist jetzt kein Hightech, der da rumsteht, aber es ist schon ein ordentliches Sendestudio mit Mischpult und Kopfhörer rein und Mikrofon und so, ein gemütliches Sofa. Und da kann man irgendwie net Radio machen. Ich hab halt jetzt diese Slots bekommen für Chaos Radio Express, immer sonntags. Und hab jetzt natürlich auch immer mal reingehört. Das heißt im Auto hör ich das und hier eben auch über Stream. Bei Micro FM gibt's eben den Stream. Und das ist halt einfach mal so schönes Lokalradio, wo es so um lokale Themen geht, aber wo auch einfach der ganze Wahnsinn abgeladen wird. Was besonders schön ist, ist, dass diese ganzen Lesebünen und Poeten da angedockt haben, teilweise auch noch ihre Aufnahmen machen. Ich mach Chaos Radio Express. Vier Sendungen. Zwei hab ich jetzt schon durch, zwei kommen noch.
Mit Lokalbezug?
Naja, nur insofern, als dass eben nur Leute da auch anrufen können. Letztes Mal hat sogar schon einer angerufen. Toll, wa? So, jetzt gucken wir mal hier. Also, auf Twitter. MC meint, er hätte sich gerade ein Drobo bestellt. Das sind natürlich noch nicht so viele Sachen. Dann meint jemand, dass meine Webseite down ist. Das stimmt. Kann ich mit Mac OS X Server keine Kalendereinträge in die Cloud sinken? Ohje, doppelte Verneinung. Also, was meint er denn wohl? Wenn man Mac OS X Server verwendet und man hat da einen Kalender, ob man das in Mobile Me rein sinken kann?
Keine Kalendereinträge in die Sound.
Naja, also man könnte jetzt auch erstmal die Frage als kann ich es überhaupt rein sinken?
Wir brauchen doch jetzt nicht ruminterpretieren. Schreib da einfach nochmal was du meinst, Stefan. BusySync übrigens, habe ich jetzt gerade noch gelesen, kann man erst seit Version 2.0 mit Google-Kalendern sinken und vorher war das nur dafür gedacht, dass man ohne einen eigenen Server zu brauchen.
Aber ist natürlich doof, wenn mehrere Leute unabhängig voneinander sind und so und nicht wissen wo sie sind. Man braucht ja einen Hub in der Mitte.
Google-Kalender ist dafür super.
Das stimmt. Ja, ansonsten wird hier nur gesagt, dass es nicht mehr zu leise ist. Das liegt daran, dass ich den Pegel ein bisschen hoch gedreht habe. Das hilft. Zwar meine Aufnahme wieder ein bisschen distortiert, aber ich gehe ja danach sowieso mit LV.
Das habe ich heute schon mal gehört. Hier wurde gerade empfohlen, dass es noch ein Backup-System gäbe. Muss man sich dann aber mal bei Gelegenheit angucken.
Dir wurde das empfohlen.
Mir wurde das gerade empfohlen.
Wir kriegen ja jetzt sozusagen alle unterschiedliche Tipps. Manche tippen mir und dir. Brauchen wir noch einen Mobile-Max? Haben wir eigentlich einen Mobile-Max auf Twitter?
Kann man eigentlich einen Account sharen?
Naja, wir können das Passwort...
Und dann können wir alle gleichzeitig drin sein?
Ja klar. Und Twitterific kann auch mehrere Accounts. Wie nee? Doch, du kannst ja die Accounts hin und her schalten.
Was? Wo seid ihr denn das? Ach, hin und her schalten?
Also ich hab das nicht so ausgiebig benutzt, aber ich dachte, dass hier gelesen zu haben, dass das geht.
Nee, aber geht das nicht? Twirl kann das.
Jetzt seh ich's auch gerade nicht.
Nee, nee, kann's nicht. Es ist geplant für eine der späteren Versionen.
Aber irgendwo hatte ich diese Funktionalität.
In Twirl wahrscheinlich.
Nee, das hab ich nicht benutzt. Das ist doch dieses adobe R-Ding. Das benutze ich nicht. Ich muss zugeben, ich bin verwirrt.
So, wir haben jetzt eigentlich auch schon langsam... Wie lange haben wir jetzt schon drauf?
Wie lange ist denn diese Sendung eigentlich? So, zwei Stunden elf Minuten.
Na komm, das ist in Anbetracht sehr Tatsache.
Darf ich mich noch noch fluchen, dass iCal auch im Jahre 2008 nicht weiß, was eine Kalenderwoche ist? Das finde ich furchtbar.
Aber was das kann, ist... Tod der Kalenderwoche.
Ich weiß, aber nur deswegen benutze ich iCals Menu, weil iCal nicht in der Lage ist, auszurechnen, wievielte Woche es gerade ist.
Ja, aber es ist schön, ein Tool zu haben, was das kann. Ich habe ewig lang nach gesucht, iCals Menu ist die einzig kostenlose Lösung, die ich kenne, mit der man sich Kalenderwochen anzeigen lassen kann.
Das ist richtig.
Insofern ist es eine Erwähnung, iCals Menu ist sowieso super.
Das stimmt.
iCals Menu Pro meint er.
Gibt es das auch ein Pro?
Nee, ohne Pro. Es gibt iCals Pro und es gibt...
Meint ihr das Dashboard-Teil, oder was meint ihr?
Nee, das in der Menü-Leiste oben.
Genau, das ist nett. Das gibt es in der Version 1.3. Das kann eine Menge Sachen. Das ist schon wirklich praktisch. Man kann sich da mehr Dinge anzeigen, als man jemals über seinen Computer wissen wollte.
Gibt es eigentlich schon ein Programm, das Sie schon immer über Ihren Computer wissen wollten, aber noch nie zu fragen waren?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das wäre ein schönes Statistik-Programm.
Okay, auf jeden Fall gibt es hier nicht mehr genug Fragen.
Also wenn wir beim nächsten Mal hier nicht irgendwo einen Trikorder haben, dann bin ich wirklich bitter enttäuscht. Es gibt noch eine Frage.
Ja, und zwar, was wir von einem Rumor halten. Jetzt muss ich aber erstmal gucken, was das ist. Neue MacBooks mit AMD-Chipset? Ich glaube nicht. Glaube ich auch nicht.
Halt dich auf für relativ unwahrscheinlich. Ich hab was gehört von unserem neuen...
Ich hab nur gelesen, dass es... Also irgendjemand hat gemutmaßt, dass Apple sogar so weit gehen würde, eigene Chipsets zu machen. Ich weiß nicht. Also es gibt natürlich Argumente dafür.
Es ist ja ein Rumor.
Es ist ein Rumor. Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher. Warum sollten sie das machen?
Eigene Chipsets?
Gut, das haben sie früher gemacht. Das haben sie für ihre Power-PC-Macintoshes getan. Und ob sie nun wirklich so beschränkt sind dadurch... Also Chipsets zu entwickeln ist jetzt nicht ohne. Man muss ja da schon auf der aktuellen Prozessorlinie hinterherlatschen.
Da gab es gerade das Gerücht, dass NVIDIA eventuell damit aufhören will. Es wurde aber gleich verneint.
Ich glaube das nicht. Ich glaube, dass sie noch eine Weile mit Intel gehen und wenn sie was Spezielles brauchen, dass sie dann eher zu Intel gehen. Und dass sie sich jetzt erstmal auf ihre Chipsets für iPhone und iPod konzentrieren. Das ist das, was ich glaube.
Hauptsache, die übernehmen sich mal nicht, so wie mit dem iPhone, 3G, Mobile Me gleichzeitig alles starten, App Store, Zeugs und wie fliegt denn alles um die Ohren? Weil die haben ja schon ganz schön viel zu tun jetzt. Auch wenn es ein riesen Laden ist, aber...
Die haben echte Probleme. Vor allem, die haben zu wenig Mitarbeiter. Die kriegen einfach keine Leute. Und an jedem dieser riesigen Projekte, über die so viel geredet wird, da arbeiten einfach nicht viele dran. Das sind alles sehr kleine Teams, was natürlich auch Vorteile hat, aber was manchmal eben auch an seine Kapazitätsgrenzen stößt.
Die bauen ja auch schon ein neues Gebäude gerade. Die sind ja nicht mehr lange in One Infinite Loop in Cupertino.
Ja, aber die müssen ja diese Leute auch überhaupt erst mal kriegen. Also, die hat ihn ja Google schon komplett weggecastet.
Ich wurde hier noch gefragt, ob wir eine Alternative zum Mobile Mecan, also wo man ein iPhone, wo man Pushmail auf dem iPhone haben kann. Ich kann keine, leider.
War auch beim letzten Mal schon, aber da fielen uns die Namen davon nicht ein.
Ernsthaft?
Nein, Exchange, Exchange Alternative.
Genau, Exchange und auf der Suche nach einer vernünftigen Exchange Alternative bin ich auch noch. Da hab ich dieses Z-Push gehabt, was ich so richtig zum Laufen noch nicht bekommen habe, wo ich dann allerdings auch was ein bisschen eingeschlafen ist, weil ob ich Spam in Echtzeit kriege oder mit 5 Minuten Verzögerung, ist mir relativ wurscht, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber eine schöne Lösung, also ich meine, das wär natürlich wirklich was für Google Mail, dass die plötzlich dann dieses Push-Mail können, hoffe ich irgendwann mal, auf dem iPhone. Dann ist die iPhone-Unterstützung von Google wahrscheinlich offiziell besser als die von Apple. Wenn sie einen freien Push-Mail-Dienst anbieten würden. Würde ich ja ganz grundlos finden.
Ja, ich dachte, das wird sich alles so ein bisschen widersprechen. Jetzt werde ich noch darauf hingewiesen, dass es natürlich abonnierbare Kalenderwochen gibt, über iCal, das ist natürlich so. Aber ich finde das ein bisschen traurig, dass man sowas überhaupt erst mal abonnieren muss. Und irgendwie der eine Dienst, wo ich das mal gemacht habe, wollte dann irgendwie Geld haben dafür und so weiter. Und für Kalenderwochen auch noch Geld zu bezahlen, ist mir dann ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen, irgendwo ist ja auch Schluss. Ich würde sagen, hier ist jetzt auch Schluss, oder?
Genau.
Ich mag jetzt nicht mehr, sonst wird das wieder so lange. Wir können jetzt noch ein paar Statistiken zusammentragen, können wir uns hier so ein bisschen mal loben.
Dennis mit einem M, bitte.
Genau.
Wie viele Follower hat Dennis nach dieser Sendung?
41, da fehlen noch 9.
41, naja, einer wäre ja noch ganz gut, oder?
Da kam direkt die Korrektur hinterher, sehr gut. Genau, einer reicht, noch ein Follower mehr.
Und wir müssen uns noch einen Mobile-Max-Account machen, das machen wir gleich, würde ich sagen. Wenn hier jetzt nicht schon jemand weggenommen hat.
Ja, so geht das in einer Live-Sendung, oder?
So ist das im Internet, das geht ratzefatze. Zuhörer haben wir 44, so gut.
Das war doch eigentlich ganz ok, oder? Als Live-Sendung, für den ersten Versuch spontan vorher gesagt, lasst mal, das fand ich großartig.
Genau, und ihr sagt uns jetzt in den Kommentaren, insbesondere die Podcast-Hörer, ob das nervt, oder ob das lustig ist, oder was auch immer. Und ob wir das hier irgendwie interaktiver machen sollen. Dann kündigen wir das in Zukunft auch im Blog vorher nochmal an.
Genau. Und im sharebaren Google-Kalender.
Und im sharebaren Google-Kalender. Mobile Me, Mobile Max, oh Gott, sind wir da nah dran. Mobile Max 2.0.
Mit eigenem Twitter-Account.
Mit eigenem Twitter-Account. Das ist wirklich der Ritterschlag.
Gut, jetzt haben wir es aber, oder?
Ja, ich denke auch. Jetzt kommt nur noch dünner Luft hier. Bis bald.